ADMINISTRATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. JUST A QUICK NOTE ON THE
DOCKET. WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOLLOWING THE DISCUSSION
ITEMS. APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION, AT THIS TIME,
WE'LL ASK TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
FOR PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. SENATOR PADILLA, PRESENT
SENATOR NEIL HERE. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. MISTER CHAIR,
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME AGAIN, EVERYBODY.
ITEMS ON THE DOCKET TODAY FOR
DISCUSSION. START WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, ISSUES
12 THROUGH 15. ASK OUR
PRESENTERS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD AND MAKE
YOURSELVES COMFORTABLE. AND
PROCEED WHEN READY AND WELCOME.
OKAY GOOD. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
PADILLA. SENATORS MY NAME IS
SCOTT DOSIK. I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES PROGRAM AT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. I KNOW
YOU'VE GOT A BIG AGENDA. I'LL
JUST KEEP IT REALLY BRIEF. I
THINK YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROGRAM AT
THIS POINT, THE RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
NEXT YEAR IS A $60 MILLION
ALLOCATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM, BUILDING
OFF OF THE SUCCESS OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
AND GRANT PROGRAMS, THE TAX
CREDIT HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED AS A
VERY EFFECTIVE PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
AT RISK FOR LEAVING CALIFORNIA
TO STAY HERE AND GROW AND CREATE
NEW FULL TIME JOBS. BUILDING OFF
OF THAT SUCCESS, THE GRANT
PROGRAM WAS CREATED ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO FOR THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT CANNOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
NONREFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT, EITHER
BECAUSE OF NET OPERATING LOSSES
OR RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDITS. THEY CANNOT USE A NON
REFUNDABLE CREDIT. IT WILL
PROVIDE NO MONETARY BENEFIT. SO
THE GRANT PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
IT HAS PROVEN SO POPULAR THAT WE
HAVE RECEIVED LITERALLY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS EACH
YEAR FOR THE $120 MILLION WE HAD
AVAILABLE. SO THE OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE FOR THIS YEAR IS WE'RE
REQUESTING FOR A $60 MILLION,
$60 MILLION APPROPRIATION. AND
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO CAPITALIZE
ON THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES OF
THE FEDERAL CHIPS ACT FUNDING
THAT DOES REQUIRE STATE AND
LOCAL MATCH. AND THE CAL
COMPETES PROGRAM IS SIMPLY THE
MOST EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR
PROVIDING THAT MATCH TO ENSURE
THAT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
POTENTIAL FEDERAL FUNDING COULD
COME TO CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. AND THEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, BRIAN
UHLER WITH THE LAO, ON THIS
ITEM, WE ARE RECOMMENDING,
REJECTING THE, PROPOSED FUNDING
AND THIS RECOMMENDATION LARGELY
IS BASED ON THE STATE'S FISCAL
POSITION, GIVEN THE PROJECTED
BUDGET DEFICITS, WE THINK THAT
IT'S PRUDENT TO FOCUS ANY
POTENTIAL ALLOCATIONS ON PROVEN
WAYS TO CARRY OUT STATE, THE
STATE'S CORE RESPONSIBILITIES OR
MEET CRITICAL NEEDS, AND IN THIS
CASE, WHILE WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE HAS BEEN SOME FAIRLY GOOD
RESEARCH WHICH HAS APPEARED TO
ESTABLISH THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE TRADITIONAL CAL COMPETES TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM, IT IS OUR
POSITION THAT THAT RESEARCH
DOESN'T NECESSARILY SPEAK TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE GRANTS
PROGRAM, WHICH IS A NEWER
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM AND HAS
SOME KEY DIFFERENCES FROM THE
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM. WE DON'T YET
HAVE ANY SORT OF OUTCOME METRICS
OR ANY EVALUATION OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE GRANTS
THEMSELVES, AND FOR THAT REASON,
WHILE IT MAY HAVE BEEN, MAY HAVE
MADE SENSE TO ALLOCATE SOME
FUNDING, IN IN RECENT YEARS WHEN
THERE WAS KIND OF MORE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO TEST OUT THIS IDEA,
WE THINK THAT THAT'S A LESS
PRUDENT, NOW, ALL THAT BEING
SAID, WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
COULD BE SOME CONCERN THAT
WITHOUT THIS FUNDING, THE STATE
MAY POTENTIALLY MISS OUT ON
FEDERAL CHIPS ACT DOLLARS COMING
INTO THE STATE. WE WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THERE ARE OTHER
POTENTIAL, RESOURCE SOURCES THAT
COULD BE USED TO PROVIDE THE
STATE INCENTIVES FOR CHIPS ACT
PROGRAMS THAT COULD INCLUDE THE
TRADITIONAL CAL COMPETES TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM, OR RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT CREDITS, OR THE NEW
EMPLOYMENT CREDIT OR OTHER
OPTIONS. WE UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALREADY
EXPLORING THESE OPTIONS AS WELL,
ONE POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVE IF YOU
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHIP
PROGRAM, COULD BE TO SET UP SORT
OF A CONTINGENT FUNDING PROCESS
WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION, UPON
DEMONSTRATING TO, THE JLBC, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT THEY HAVE
EXHAUSTED ALL THE OTHER
POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES FOR
FUNDING FOR CHIP STACKS PROGRAM
COULD COME AND MAKE A REQUEST
FOR CAL COMPETES GRANT FUNDING
FOR THAT PROJECT, WITH THAT, I'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I THANK YOU, COLBY
WHITE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS, BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. ON THE PROGRAM SIDE, I'D
LIKE TO HEAR ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE LACK OF EMPIRICAL DATA
YET TO KNOW WHETHER WHAT'S BEING
ABLE TO ADEQUATELY MEASURE THE
IMPACT AND EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
GRANT PROGRAM. IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THOSE A LITTLE MORE
DEEPLY AND, AGAIN, A LITTLE A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT PUTTING AT
RISK LEVERAGING OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS. THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR
THE QUESTION. SO A COUPLE OF
THINGS. SO BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT AND GRANT
PROGRAMS HAVE VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL EVALUATION CRITERIA.
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL SELECTION
CRITERIA. THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TAX CREDIT AND THE
GRANT PROGRAM IS THAT THE GRANT
PROGRAM HAS AN ADDITIONAL LEVEL
OF SCRUTINY, WHERE WE VALIDATE
WHETHER THAT APPLICANT THAT
BUSINESS TRULY CANNOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE NONREFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE COMPANIES APPLYING AND BEING
SELECTED FOR THE GRANT NEED THE
GRANT AND CANNOT TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF A NON REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT.
BUT AS FAR AS THE EVALUATION
CRITERIA FOR THAT ARE THE BASIS
FOR THE AWARDS, THEY ARE
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL FOR THE
GRANT PROGRAM. AS FOR THE TAX
CREDIT, AS FAR AS EMPIRICAL DATA
IS CONCERNED, WHENEVER A COMPANY
IS AWARDED EITHER A CAL COMPETES
TAX CREDIT OR GRANT AWARD, THEY
SIGN A FIVE YEAR CONTRACT THAT
LAYS OUT HOW MUCH THEY WILL
RECEIVE EACH YEAR OVER THE FIVE
YEAR PERIOD, IF THEY ACHIEVE THE
MILESTONES THAT THEY LAID OUT IN
THEIR APPLICATION, SPECIFICALLY,
THE NUMBER OF NEW FULL TIME JOBS
ARE GOING TO CREATE AND
MAINTAINING THEIR EXISTING
EMPLOYMENT LEVELS. THE MINIMUM
AND AVERAGE SALARIES FOR THE NEW
FULL TIME EMPLOYEES AND THE
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS THAT THEY
COMMITTED TO AS PART OF THEIR
APPLICATION. SO WE SO FAR, I
MEAN, IT'S KIND OF DIFFICULT TO
SAY FOR A PROGRAM THAT'S ROUGHLY
THREE YEARS OLD, IF THE PROGRAM
HAS PROVEN SUCCESSFUL, WE CAN
TELL YOU THAT THERE ARE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE APPLIED THAT
WOULD NOT HAVE APPLIED FOR THE
TAX CREDIT, THAT NOW HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE TAX CREDIT, THE GRANT
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY FOR CHIPS
ACT. AND I'M THINKING ABOUT
COMPANIES LIKE APPLIED MATERIALS
AND LAM THAT WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
TAX CREDIT THAT APPLIED FOR THE
GRANT AND ARE USING THAT AS THE
BASIS FOR THEIR CHIPS. AWARDS
THEIR CHIPS GRANT APPLICATIONS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE'LL
BRING IT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS, SENATOR
NILO, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M
ALL FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES. I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT LOCALLY
FOR 30 YEARS, BUT BUT TO THIS
POINT, IT'S MY ASSESSMENT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
NON-SERIOUS ABOUT THE BUDGET GAP
THAT WE HAVE, HOPEFULLY, WHEN
THE MAY REVISE COMES OUT THAT,
THE ADMINISTRATION, EXCUSE ME,
WILL COME OFF OF ITS EXTREMELY
LOW, ESTIMATE AS TO WHAT THE
DEFICIT IS, MANY MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS LESS THAN WHAT THE LAO
HAS OPINED, AS REVENUES HAVE
CONTINUED TO DECREASE, WE HAD
EARLY ACTION PRESENTED TO US
THAT REALLY HASN'T EVEN FORMALLY
BEEN ADOPTED YET, EXCEPT FOR THE
MSO TAX. AND OF THAT, ONLY ABOUT
20% OF IT WAS ACTUAL PROGRAM
REDUCTIONS, MEANING THAT REALLY
THE BULK OF THE DEFICIT, IN
TERMS OF PROGRAM REDUCTIONS, HAS
TO BE TAKEN OUT OF THE COMING
BUDGET YEAR. AND AND, NOW THESE
ARE OVERALL COMMENTS BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN KIND OF FRUSTRATED
WATCHING IT, AND I AM RELEGATED
TO WATCHING IT, BUT AGAIN, AS
MUCH AS I FAVOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES, THIS IS
EXACTLY THE SORT OF THING UNDER
THE PRESSURE BUDGET PRESSURE
THAT WE HAVE, THAT WE SHOULD NOT
BE AUGMENTING, WE REALLY DON'T
KNOW HOW WELL IT WORKS, AND IT'S
NOT REALLY THE CORE FUNCTION OF
STATE GOVERNMENT, SO I HAVE TO
SPEAK STRONGLY AGAINST THIS
AUGMENTATION. THÀNH SENATOR
CUEVAS, THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION. COULD YOU CAN YOU
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE, SORT OF MILESTONES OR,
BENCHMARKS THAT COMPANIES ARE TO
RECEIVE OR REACH IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE THE GRANTS? YOU
MENTIONED EMPLOYMENT, SALARIES
AND CAPITAL INVESTMENTS. AND I
JUST WONDER, DOES THAT THOSE
THREE I DON'T KNOW IF THOSE ARE
THE THREE MAJOR MILESTONES AND
DOES IT CHANGE DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE BUSINESS IS, JUST WANT TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT THE MILESTONES
AND HOW OUR BUSINESSES SORT OF
MEASURED IN TERMS OF THE ABILITY
TO REACH THOSE MILESTONES. AND
DOES IT CHANGE BY BUSINESS? SIR,
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION,
SENATOR. APPRECIATE IT. SO FOR
THE MOST PART, YOU'RE CORRECT.
SO IF THE LAST PAGE OF EVERY
AGREEMENT, EVERY CONTRACT, IT'S
ABOUT AN 8 OR 9 PAGE AGREEMENT,
THAT IF YOU BOIL IT DOWN, REALLY
SAYS HERE'S HOW MUCH CREDIT YOU
CAN CLAIM OR HOW MUCH GRANTS YOU
CAN RECEIVE IF YOU DO WHAT YOU
SAID YOU WERE GOING TO DO AND AS
FAR AS THE MILESTONES THAT ARE
LISTED, IT IS THE SO THE
DIFFERENT ROWS ON THERE ARE. THE
FIRST ROW IS THE TOTAL FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT, SO THE BASE YEAR
WHICH MEANING THE YEAR PRIOR TO
THEM APPLYING FOR THE GRANT OR
THE TAX CREDIT AND THEN THEIR
PROJECTED TOTAL FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT OVER EACH OF THE FIVE
YEARS OF THE GRANT PERIOD, THE
NEXT ROW IS BASICALLY A
MATHEMATICAL FORMULA THAT SHOWS
THE NET INCREASE OF FULL TIME
JOBS COMPARED TO THE BASE YEAR,
AND WE DO THIS SPECIFICALLY SO
THAT IT'S NOT JUST HIRING,
RIGHT? YOU CAN'T JUST HIRE
SOMEONE ON DECEMBER 15TH AND LAY
THEM OFF ON JANUARY SECOND AND
SAY, OH, LOOK, I CREATED ALL
THESE JOBS. WE'RE MEASURING THE
FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT, THE NEXT
TWO ROWS ARE THE MINIMUM AND
AVERAGE SALARIES THAT THEY
COMMITTED TO FOR EACH OF THEIR
NEW FULL TIME EMPLOYEES. SO THEY
MIGHT SAY THE LOWEST PAID
EMPLOYEE WE'RE GOING TO HIRE FOR
THE NEW JOBS WE'RE CREATING WILL
MAKE $50,000 A YEAR, BUT AN
AVERAGE OF 85,000 OR 100,000 OR
WHATEVER THE AVERAGE HAPPENS TO
BE, AND THEN THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS FOR NEW, REAL OR
PERSONAL PROPERTY THAT IS PAID
FOR AND PLACED INTO SERVICE
AFTER THE APPLICATION DEADLINE.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, THERE'S NO
RETROACTIVITY TO THE INVESTMENT.
SO THEY REPORT SO COMPANIES SIGN
THIS CONTRACT. THEY REPORT TO US
ANNUALLY ON THEIR PROGRESS. IF
THEY DO NOT ACHIEVE ALL OF THE
MILESTONES FOR ANY GIVEN YEAR,
THEY DO NOT GET TO TAKE THE
ALLOCATION FOR THAT YEAR. BUT
THEY DO HAVE ALL FIVE YEARS OF
THE AGREEMENT TO PLAY CATCH UP,
BECAUSE WHEN COMPANIES ARE
LOOKING INTO THEIR CRYSTAL BALL
FOR FIVE YEARS OUT, SOMETIMES IT
GETS A LITTLE MURKY. WHEN YOU
GET MORE THAN, SAY, SIX MONTHS
OUT. WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOUR
PROJECTIONS, LIKEWISE, THERE'S A
MAJOR ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS
BUILT INTO CALIFORNIA, COMPETES
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD PERFORMS
A FAIRLY RIGOROUS BOOKS AND
RECORDS REVIEW OF EACH OF THE
AWARDEES TO VALIDATE THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
THE APPLICATION AS FAR AS THEIR
BASE YEAR, EMPLOYMENT AND THOSE
EMPLOYMENT, SALARY AND
INVESTMENT NUMBERS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO GO-BIZ. CAN YOU AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A
PERCENT OR HOW YOU KIND OF
DOCUMENT SUCCESS, BUT DO MOST
COMPANIES I GUESS THERE WERE
THERE 23 BUSINESSES AWARDED
THESE GRANTS I THINK WAS IN THE
ANALYSIS. HOW MANY OF THEM
ACTUALLY MET THE BENCHMARKS? MET
THE GOAL? WHAT DOES THAT SUCCESS
PERCENTAGE LOOK LIKE? SO WE ONLY
HAVE THREE YEARS OF GRANT DATA.
SO FAR, I CAN TELL YOU THAT EACH
OF THE BUSINESSES THAT HAS
APPLIED HAVE BEEN AWARDED A
GRANT IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THEIR ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS, YOU KNOW, THE A
LOT OF THE TIMES WHEN THEY'RE
APPLYING FOR THESE GRANTS, THE
PROJECTS ARE TWO, THREE, FOUR
YEARS OUT, LIKE THE, YOU KNOW,
IF THERE'S A LOT OF CAPITAL
INVESTMENT THAT HAS TO HAPPEN,
LIKE, SAY, FOR EXAMPLE, BUILDING
A MASSIVE, RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT FACILITY FOR
SEMICONDUCTOR R&D, YOU HAVE TO
BUILD THE FACILITY BEFORE YOU'RE
GOING TO HIRE THE EMPLOYEES. AND
SO YOU MAY NOT SEE SUCCESS FOR
THREE, 4 OR 5 YEARS, SO IT'S
KIND OF DIFFICULT TO SAY WHETHER
THEY WILL ACHIEVE. BUT ONE OF
THE NICE THINGS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM IS WE DO HAVE THOSE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS. IF A
COMPANY DOES NOT ACHIEVE THE
MILESTONES, ANY OF THEM, OR IF
FTB DETERMINES THAT THERE WAS AN
ERROR IN THEIR SUBMISSION AND
BASED ON THEIR AUDIT BOOKS AND
RECORDS REVIEW, THE COMPANY
DIDN'T ACHIEVE, WE GET THE MONEY
BACK EITHER BY RECAPTURING AND
BRINGING IT BACK. AND FTB HAS
ALL THE TOOLS IN THEIR ARSENAL
FOR THE GRANT PROGRAM, AS THEY
DO FOR THE TAX CREDIT TO BE ABLE
TO, FOR EXAMPLE, FILE LIENS AND
GO AFTER, YOU KNOW, GET BANK
ACCOUNTS, THINGS OF THAT NATURE
TO ENSURE THAT ACCOUNTABILITY IS
BUILT INTO THE PROGRAM. OKAY.
AND YOU SAID IT'S BEEN THREE
YEARS. SO WE DON'T HAVE WE CAN'T
MEASURE THAT THIS IS SUCCESSFUL
YET BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T REACHED
THE FIVE YEAR. CORRECT? YEAH.
THE INDICATIONS ARE THAT MOST OF
THE COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN
AWARDED ARE MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS THEIR MILESTONES,
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE
ALL FIVE YEARS, ACHIEVE SOME
INCREMENTAL PROGRESS IS TOO
EARLY TO SAY, WE ARE FAIRLY
CONFIDENT THAT A HIGH SUCCESS
RATE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FACT
THAT THIS PROGRAM WAS BUILT ON
THE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM, THAT AND
THERE IS A RECENT PPIC REPORT
THAT DOCUMENTS IN LAO REFERENCED
THIS, THAT THIS PROGRAM HAS
PROVEN VERY EFFECTIVE AT
GENERATING NEW FULL TIME JOB
CREATION IN THE AREAS, WHERE THE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN AWARDED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE? IF NOT,
THAT ISSUE WILL BE HELD OPEN.
WE'LL MOVE TO 13, WHICH DEALS
WITH THE SAVINGS FROM UNUSED CAL
COMPETES TAX CREDITS. I THINK
WE'LL ASK A FAVOR OF THE LAO TO
READ THAT TITLE ITEM IN. IT'S
SORT OF AN UNOFFICIAL REPORT.
SURE SO ISSUE NUMBER 13 IS FOR
POTENTIAL SAVINGS FROM UNUSED
CAL COMPETES TAX CREDITS. SO THE
PROGRAM UNDER STATUTE IS A IS A
PERMITTED TO AWARD $180 MILLION
IN CREDITS EACH YEAR. AS THE
ADMINISTRATION DESCRIBED, THERE
IS A RIGOROUS PROCESS FOR THE
BUSINESSES DOCUMENTING THAT
THEY'VE MET THEIR MILESTONES IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO CLAIM THE
CREDIT. AND WHEN THOSE
MILESTONES AREN'T MET, THE
CREDITS ARE RECAPTURED AND THE
BUSINESSES ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
CLAIM THOSE CREDITS, WHEN THE
CREDITS ARE RECAPTURED, EXISTING
LAW ALLOWS, THE DEPARTMENT TO
ESSENTIALLY ADD THOSE TO THE
$180 MILLION TO INCREASE THE POT
OF CREDITS THAT THEY CAN AWARD
IN FUTURE YEARS, AND CAL
COMPETES, ESTIMATES RIGHT NOW
THAT BECAUSE OF THAT, THEY HAVE
492 MILLION AVAILABLE TO AWARD,
IN IN THE CURRENT YEAR, THIS
ITEM IS EXPLORING THE
POSSIBILITY OF RESTRICTING THE,
THE ABILITY OF GO-BIZ TO
RE-AWARD THOSE RECAPTURED
CREDITS IN FUTURE YEARS AND
LIMITING THEIR ALLOCATION TO THE
180 MILLION THAT IS SPELLED OUT
IN STATUTE, WOULD YOU DO YOU
WANT ME TO MAKE MY COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM NOW, OR HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT SPEAK FIRST? LET'S GO
TO THE DEPARTMENT AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL KIND OF TAKE ADDITIONAL
COMMENT ON THAT BEFORE WE COME
IN. PLEASE FEEL FREE. MISS, DO
YOU WANT TO LEAD THAT ANSWER
THIS QUESTION, YEAH. COLBY WHITE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO JUST,
SPEAKING TO THE REVENUE, THE
REVENUE IMPACT HERE. SO THIS IS
A, WHEN YOU REDUCE ALLOCATIONS
TO THE CAL COMPETES TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM, THERE ARE CONSIDERABLE
LAGS AS FAR AS HOW IT ENDS UP IN
RESULTING IN REVENUE LOSSES. SO,
COMPANIES MUST FIRST THERE'S THE
ALLOCATION. THE COMPANIES MUST
ARE AWARDED. IT'S OVER FIVE
YEARS. THEY MUST MEET THESE
MILESTONES, AND THEN THEY MUST
CLAIM THESE CREDITS ON A TAX
RETURN. SO, SO THE ACTUAL
BUDGETARY SAVINGS ARE RELATIVELY
SMALL IN THE NEAR TERM, AND THEN
THEY GROW A BIT OVER TIME, YOU
KNOW, LEO HAS AN ESTIMATE.
THERE'S CONSIDERABLE ASSUMPTIONS
THAT GO INTO THAT. WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THAT. THAT ESTIMATE GIVES YOU
KIND OF THE GENERAL PROFILE OF
WHAT THE WHAT THE REVENUE LOSSES
WOULD LOOK LIKE. THANK YOU. AND,
DID YOU WANT TO COMMENT
GENERALLY AS A, PROGRAM OPERATOR
OR JUST GO RIGHT TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I HAVE A
COUPLE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE? WELL,
TO THE TO BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
AND LEO'S COMMENTS, HAVE WE
THOUGHT ABOUT LOOKS LIKE
COMPOUNDING UNALLOCATED, WITH NO
RESTRICTIONS HAS SOME
SUBSTANTIAL POTENTIAL BUDGET
SAVINGS IMPACT IN THE LONG RUN?
HAVE WE THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE, AND ARE THERE
COMMENTS ON THE PRELIMINARY
ESTIMATES THAT LEO HAS GIVEN ON
WHAT THAT POTENTIAL SAVINGS
COULD BE IF WE PUT RESTRICTIONS
ON THAT RECYCLING OF UNALLOCATED
CREDIT? SO, IN ADDITION TO THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE AT
FINANCE, I DO WANT TO ACTUALLY
EMPHASIZE SOMETHING THAT HE
SAID, WHICH IS THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIVE LAG TIME IN WHEN A
CREDIT IS AWARDED VERSUS WHEN
IT'S ACTUALLY CLAIMED ON A TAX
RETURN. I WALKED THROUGH PRETTY
THOROUGHLY HOW THE FIVE YEAR
AGREEMENTS WORK OUT, AND THEN,
AS YOU KNOW, FINANCE MENTIONED.
SO IF A COMPANY IS APPROVED FOR
A TAX CREDIT, SAY, A MILESTONE,
IT'S A FIVE YEAR CONTRACT THAT
RUNS FROM IT'S AWARDED NEXT YEAR
WOULD RUN FROM 25 THROUGH 2627,
2020 THROUGH 2029. IF THEY
ACHIEVE THEIR 2025 MILESTONES,
THEY'D BE ABLE TO CLAIM THEIR 25
CREDIT ALLOCATION WHEN THEY FILE
THEIR 25 RETURN IN 2026. AND
MOST OF THE TIME WHEN YOU'RE
FILING A TAX RETURN, MOST
BUSINESSES CAN'T SAY ALMOST.
THEY FILE AN EXTENSION, WHICH
MEANS THAT THEY'RE NOT FILING
THEIR TAX RETURN UNTIL THE FALL,
WHICH MEANS YOU'RE NOW
PROJECTING OUT TO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR. SO THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT LAG TIME, THE OTHER
POINT I WOULD JUST ADD IS AND
NOT DISAGREEING WITH LEO'S
ANALYSIS, BUT SIMPLY ADDING TO
IT THAT ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
THERE IS A INCREASED ALLOCATION
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW. SO IT IS
THE ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS OF
THE PROGRAM WHERE COMPANIES THAT
DON'T ACHIEVE THEIR MILESTONES,
THOSE CREDITS ARE RECAPTURED AND
BROUGHT BACK IN TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO OTHER BUSINESSES,
BUT ALSO UNALLOCATED CREDITS. WE
ARE VERY RIGOROUS IN OUR
EVALUATION OF APPLICANTS. AND IF
A COMPANY, IF WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH QUALITY APPLICATIONS
WHERE COMPANIES HAVE THOROUGHLY
DEMONSTRATED THAT THIS CREDIT
WOULD BE A MATERIAL FACTOR IN
THEIR DECISION OR ABILITY TO
CREATE NEW FULL TIME JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA, WE WON'T AWARD THE
FUNDS. WE'RE WE'RE VERY THOROUGH
AND VERY RIGOROUS IN OUR
EVALUATION OF THESE APPLICANTS.
I UNDERSTAND THE MERIT AND I
UNDERSTAND THE MECHANICS. I
THINK THE QUESTION WAS, IS THERE
A DISPUTE WITH THE NOTATION
THAT'S BEEN MADE IN THE ANALYSIS
BY LAO THAT IF WE PUT A
LIMITATION ON THE REALLOCATION
OF THE CREDIT AS IT ON BOND, I
MEAN THAT THAT ADDS UP TO SOME
POTENTIAL SAVINGS, TO IN TERMS
OF THE EXPENDITURE SIDE, NET NET
COST TO THE STATE. AND DID YOU
HAVE ANY DISPUTE WITH THEIR
ESTIMATE ON THAT? SO COLBY
WHITE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
AS I MENTIONED, THERE ARE
CONSIDERABLE LAGS AND THE
PROFILE, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T HAVE
ANY DISPUTE WITH IT. I MEAN, WE
THINK IT'S A LITTLE ACCELERATED.
IT'S, GENERALLY, BUT, BUT THE
GENERAL MAGNITUDES, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE LÀ
ESTIMATE AS 5 MILLION BUDGETARY
SAVINGS AND 24, 25 AND THEN
RAMPING UP TO 45 MILLION
ONGOING, BY OUTSIDE OF THE MULTI
YEAR, SO, YEAH, THOSE THOSE ARE
REASONABLE NUMBERS. I MEAN, WE
COULD. YEAH. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SIR, TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR FOLLOW UP THE
SENATOR NILO, THE, JUST TO
CLARIFY, THE 492 MILLION THAT'S
AVAILABLE, IS THAT, ARE THOSE
FUNDS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ALLOCATED OR HAVE BEEN, NOT
CLAIMED, WHAT WHAT'S THE ACTUAL
NATURE OF THAT MONEY? SURE.
SENATOR IT'S A MIXTURE. SO IT'S
A COMBINATION OF THE $180
MILLION ANNUAL ALLOCATION FOR
THE PROGRAM. ANY CREDITS THAT
WERE RECAPTURED FROM THE
PREVIOUS FISCAL YEAR, AND THOSE
ARE COMPANIES THAT DID NOT
ACHIEVE THEIR MILESTONES. AND
THUS THAT PORTION OF THE CREDIT
WAS RETURNED TO GO-BIZ, AND THEN
IT'S ANY CREDITS THAT WERE NOT
ALLOCATED FROM THE PREVIOUS
FISCAL YEAR BECAUSE THE EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE HAD WE'RE ALWAYS
OVERSUBSCRIBED. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER, IF THEIR APPLICATION IS
DOES NOT PASS THE RIGOROUS
REVIEW OF DEMONSTRATING THAT
THIS CREDIT IS A MATERIAL FACTOR
IN THEIR GROWTH DECISIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, WE WON'T JUST GIVE
THE MONEY AWAY, AS FAR AS NOT
CLAIMED THING, THAT'S KIND OF AN
INTERESTING ASPECT TO IT. IF A
COMPANY ACHIEVES ITS MILESTONES
BUT IS UNABLE TO USE THE CREDIT
LIKE SOME COMPANIES THINK,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PROFITABLE
IN A FEW YEARS, AND FOR WHATEVER
REASONS, EITHER THEIR OWN
INTERNAL ECONOMICS OR THEY START
REINVESTING IN A NEW PRODUCT OR
A NEW RESEARCH, AND THEY END UP
STILL HAVING NET OPERATING
LOSSES OR R&D CREDITS. WE HAVE
SEEN THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
EARN THE CREDIT, THEY DO APPLY
IT ON THEIR TAX RETURN, BUT IT
NEVER ACTUALLY GETS MONETIZED
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PAYING
INCOME TAXES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AT WHICH POINT THAT
CREDIT IS BRAUNTON'S PURPOSE IS
LOST. AND YOU COULD SAY THE
STATE GETS THE JOBS WITHOUT ANY
FINANCIAL REPERCUSSIONS,
HALLELUJAH. SIR, WITH REGARD TO,
THE FORMER OF THE REVERTED,
THOSE THAT DIDN'T MEET THE GOAL
AND DIDN'T EVENTUALLY QUALIFY
FOR THE CREDIT. HOW MUCH OF THE
492 IS THAT? I DON'T HAVE THOSE
EXACT NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT WE COULD GET THOSE TO. OKAY,
WELL, IT'S A CURIOSITY QUESTION,
IT, WOULDN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF MY RECOMMENDATION,
WHICH YOU PROBABLY WON'T BE
SURPRISED IS TO, REVERT THESE
FUNDS TO THE GENERAL FUND, I'LL
CALL ON MY PREVIOUS, WORDS AND
NOT REPEAT THEM AGAIN. BUT WITH
THE LEVEL OF DEFICIT THAT WE
HAVE, AND THE NATURE OF THIS
PROGRAM AS, AS WORTHY AS IT IS,
AS I SAID, I'M ALL FOR, THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HELPING IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES, BUT NOT WHEN WE HAVE
THIS KIND OF DEFICIT. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, AND, I'M JUST CURIOUS
IN TERMS OF AND WE DON'T KNOW,
THE PERCENTAGE OF HOW MANY
COMPANIES DIDN'T MEET THE
BENCHMARKS AND THOSE WERE
RECAPTURED, BUT I'M CURIOUS,
WHAT ARE THE STEPS TO SUPPORT
COMPANIES IN REACHING THE
BENCHMARKS? BECAUSE IF IT'S
EMPLOYMENT, IF IT'S CAPITAL
INVESTMENT, IF IT'S, YOU KNOW,
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE PAYING
LIVING WAGE SALARIES AND
TRACKING THAT THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT OUTCOMES FOR THE
STATE. SO I'M CURIOUS, WE DON'T
KNOW THE PERCENTAGE, BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
CREDITS LEFT OVER. SO THERE. SO
IT MUST BE A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
THAT ARE BEING RECAPTURED. AND
I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT ARE THE
STEPS TO MONITOR IN REAL TIME
AND TO SUPPORT SUPPORT THOSE
INDUSTRIES IN REACHING THE
BENCHMARKS, THAT'S ONE. AND THEN
MY SECOND QUESTION IS, ALONG THE
LINES OF SENATOR NILO. BUT I'M
JUST CURIOUS, WHAT ARE WHAT ARE
YOU ALL THINKING? ARE THE
ALTERNATIVE WAYS THAT THESE,
UNUSED TAX CREDITS SHOULD BE
USED, GIVEN YOUR PROXIMITY TO
BUSINESS AND, THE GOALS OF
GO-BIZ? SURE. I'LL TRY TO GIVE A
SHORT, DIRECT ANSWER. AND IF YOU
NEED MORE INFORMATION, THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROGRAM
ITSELF DOES NOT PROVIDE. HAD A
LOT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
BUSINESSES AS THEY'RE OPERATING.
WE DO PROVIDE AN INORDINATE
AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND ENSURING
THAT EVERY BUSINESS OF EVERY
SIZE HAS THE ABILITY TO SUBMIT
AN ACCURATE APPLICATION, SO THAT
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN A STRONG
APPLICANT VERSUS A STRONG
APPLICATION. THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY FROM A STRONG
APPLICANT OR VICE VERSA. SO AN
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON THE FRONT END, WE
ALSO, AS REQUESTED FROM
BUSINESSES, WILL MAKE REFERRALS
TO THEM TO OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN
GO-BIZ. FOR EXAMPLE, OUR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS INVESTMENT
SERVICES UNIT, WHICH PROVIDES
SITE SELECTION ASSISTANCE,
CONNECTION TO OTHER RESOURCES,
ESPECIALLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
CONNECTING THEM TO, SOME
EVERYTHING FROM WEBS AND JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO, THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT RATES FOR
MANUFACTURING WHERE THEY CAN GET
DISCOUNTED UTILITIES AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE, AS FAR AS YOUR
SECOND QUESTION ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
HOW ELSE TO USE THESE FUNDS, I
CAN ONLY EMPHASIZE, I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A LARGER BUDGETARY
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEYOND MY
PURVIEW AS FAR AS THE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT. YOU KNOW,
AS WE'VE DEMONSTRATED, THESE
FUNDS WILL STAY THERE AND NOT BE
AWARDED. IT'S INTERESTING,
RIGHT, BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY FUNDS, RIGHT. IT'S
AUTHORITY TO CLAIM A CREDIT ON A
TAX RETURN. WE WILL NOT AWARD
THOSE CREDITS IF THE BUSINESSES
ARE NOT TRULY DEMONSTRATING THAT
THESE CREDITS ARE GOING TO BE A
MATERIAL FACTOR IN THEIR
DECISION TO STAY AND GROW OR
COME TO CALIFORNIA AND CREATE
FULL TIME JOBS. SO AND IF THEY
DO, THEN WE HAVE THE PICK REPORT
THAT WE CAN RELY ON THAT SHOWS
THAT THIS PROGRAM DOES RESULT IN
NET NEW JOBS IN THE AREAS WHERE
THOSE CREDITS GO OUT TO THAT
HAVE OTHER ECONOMIC BENEFITS,
YOU KNOW, THEY CREATE JOBS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE PAYING INCOME
TAX ON A REGULAR BASIS. FOR
EXAMPLE, THE GIFT THAT KEEPS ON
GIVING, IN ADDITION TO THE
UPFRONT ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF THE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS OF THEIR NEW
FACILITY OR THEIR UPGRADES OR
THEIR TENANT IMPROVEMENTS, THE
OTHER POTENTIAL DOWNSIDE OF
REDUCING THE ALLOCATION IS, WE
ARE, BY STATUTE, LIMITED TO
AWARDING TO ANY COMPANY AT MOST
20% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT
AVAILABLE PER FISCAL YEAR. SO IN
THEORY, WITH $492 MILLION
AVAILABLE THIS YEAR, WE COULD
HAVE AWARDED A CREDIT UP TO $98
MILLION. WE HAVE NOT COME
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO THAT $98
MILLION FIGURE, BUT HAVING THAT
OUT THERE, IF YOU THINK ABOUT
LARGE PROJECTS, THE TYPES OF
COMPANIES THAT WE WOULD HOPE TO
ATTRACT TO CALIFORNIA TO AND
RETAIN IN CALIFORNIA, HAVING
THAT PROSPECT OUT THERE COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFICIAL TO THE
STATE IN ATTRACTING REALLY LARGE
COMPANIES TO POTENTIALLY MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA. THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
CONSIDERED DOING SO, BECAUSE IF
YOU WERE TO COMPARE CALIFORNIA,
THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROGRAMS
WITH PROGRAMS THAT OTHER STATES
OFFER, IF YOU THINK ABOUT JUST
THE NEWS ARTICLES YOU'VE READ
ABOUT WHAT COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
OFFERED TO BUILD SEMICONDUCTOR
MANUFACTURING PLANTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN OTHER STATES, THEY
DWARF THE ENTIRE APPROPRIATION,
THE ENTIRE ALLOCATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMPETES WITH ROOM TO
SPARE. THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND I
HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION AND KIND
OF MAYBE GOES BACK TO WHAT BOTH
ITEMS IN THE IN THE TRACKING OF
THE JOB, JOBS AND SALARIES OR
POSITIONS CREATED AND SALARIES,
IS THERE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AND
GEOGRAPHIC DATA? I ASK THAT,
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IN OUR
REPORTING, WE'RE LOOKING, YOU
KNOW, 3000 FOOT HUGE AGGREGATE,
BUT WE'RE ALSO DEALING WITH SUCH
DISPARITIES IN THE STATE AND
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW THESE
RESOURCES ARE COMING BACK TO
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. IS
THERE A DATA TO HELP SORT OF
REALLY LOOK AT NOT JUST WHAT
JOBS ARE BEING CREATED AND, AND
WHAT CAPITAL INVESTMENTS ARE
BEING MADE, BUT WHERE THEY'RE
BEING MADE. AND IS IT SORT OF
NOT JUST HELPING CALIFORNIA
BUILD A WORKFORCE, BUT ALSO
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST ACROSS
THE STATE? SO I JUST THAT WAS A
QUESTION THAT CAME TO MIND. AND
THEN I'LL CLOSE. THANK YOU. SO
EVERY SINGLE TAX CREDIT AND
GRANT AWARD IS LISTED ON OUR
WEBSITE. SO THE CAL COMPETE
SAYS, YOU KNOW, I'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS. THERE'S ALSO AN
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF
TRANSPARENCY WITH THIS PROGRAM.
SO EVERY COMPANY THAT'S BEEN
AWARDED IS LISTED ON OUR WEBSITE
ALONG WITH THEIR A LIST OF THEIR
COMMITMENTS AS I DESCRIBED
PREVIOUSLY, AND A LINK TO THEIR
ACTUAL CONTRACT. SO YOU CAN SEE
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THAT THEY
COMMITTED TO. AND WHAT, IF ANY,
AMOUNT WAS EVENTUALLY RECAPTURED
FROM THOSE BUSINESSES. SO THAT
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE. WE
NOTICED WHEN THIS PROGRAM WAS
CREATED A LITTLE OVER A DECADE
AGO, WE LOOKED AT OTHER STATE
PROGRAMS. THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
REPORTING ABOUT WERE THEY
SUCCESSFUL, AND SO WE MADE A
POINT OF DECIDING TO LIST THE
AMOUNTS RECAPTURED FROM EACH OF
THOSE BUSINESSES. PART OF THE
EVALUATION CRITERIA IS LOOKING
AT THE EXTENT OF POVERTY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE REGION,
WHERE THE JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
CREATED. AND NOW WE ARE SOMEWHAT
CONSTRAINED AS THE MAJOR
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA TEND TO
BE IN THE MORE COASTAL AREAS. WE
DO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AS PART
OF THE APPLICATION PROCESS WHEN
A COMPANY FOR I'LL JUST MAKE UP
SOME THEORETICAL EXAMPLES FROM
BAY AREA SILICON VALLEY, YOU
KNOW, LOS ANGELES IS TALKING
ABOUT THEORETICALLY LOOKING TO
MOVE OR EXPAND IN A NEIGHBORING
STATE LIKE ARIZONA AND NEVADA
BECAUSE OF THE DECREASED LABOR
COSTS OR LOWER REAL ESTATE COSTS
. FIRST CONVERSATION I HAVE WITH
THEM IS, HAVE YOU CONSIDERED THE
INLAND EMPIRE? HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR
IMPERIAL? YOU CAN SAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY ON LABOR AND REAL
ESTATE COSTS SIMPLY BY MOVING
FURTHER EAST IN THE STATE. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN WE DO GET
COMPANIES THAT THEY'RE DOING
THAT COST ANALYSIS, AND THEY
REALIZE THEY CAN'T HAVE THOSE
SAVINGS. BUT THERE'S STILL AT A
COST DISADVANTAGE. AND AN
EXAMPLE MIGHT BE RECENT AWARDEE
PACIFIC STEEL, WHICH IS
PROPOSING TO OPEN THE FIRST NEW
STEEL MILL IN CALIFORNIA IN OVER
50 YEARS. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
IT'S GOING TO BE IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD, THE GREENEST STEEL
MANUFACTURING PLANT EVER BUILT,
MASSIVE SOLAR ARRAYS, BATTERY
ENERGY STORAGE, AND IT'S GOING
TO BE BUILT AND MAINTAINED BY
IRONWORKERS, IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST SUSTAINABLE NEW IRON OR
STEEL MILLS EVER CREATED. IT'S
GOING TO BE BUILT IN KERN IN THE
MOJAVE AREA, WHERE AN EXTENSIVE
AMOUNT OF POPULATION HAS
HISTORICALLY LIVED AND CONTINUES
TO LIVE IN POVERTY WITH HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES, ALONG WITH
LOCAL HIGHER PROVISIONS. THOSE
ARE THE TYPES OF COMPANIES WE
LOVE TO GET AND THEY EVEN TALKED
IN THEIR APPLICATION. AND AT THE
COMMITTEE MEETING, A WEEK AGO
ABOUT THE COST, BENEFITS OF
DOING THIS IN ONE OF THE
NEIGHBORING STATES VERSUS
CALIFORNIA. BUT THIS TAX CREDIT
WAS THAT MISSING PIECE THAT
PUSHED THEM OVER THE EDGE TO
COMMIT TO THIS PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA WITH MASSIVE
INVESTMENTS IN OVER IN ABOUT 500
NEW FULL TIME QUALITY JOBS. SO
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE EACH,
APPLICATION HAS CERTAIN CRITERIA
THAT THEY'RE OR METHODS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO USE TO REACH
THE BENCHMARKS, BUT IT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE GO-BIZ IS TRACKING
WITHIN THAT IN TERMS OF WHAT
GETS PROJECTED ONLINE IN TERMS
OF WHERE THOSE HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
, POVERTY COMMUNITIES ARE AND
HOW THE COMPANIES ARE WORKING
AND ADDRESSING THAT POPULATION.
THERE'S NOTHING TRACKING IN THE
DATA TO SORT OF WHAT COMMUNITIES
ARE BEING CALLED IN TO THE
OPPORTUNITIES SPECIFICALLY. BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S SOME
PROCESS THAT'S LAID OUT IN THE
APPLICATION, BUT NOT A, NOT NOT
A TRANSPARENT WAY OF TRACKING
THAT FOR THE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
SEE. I THINK THAT IS THAT RIGHT?
OKAY. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO THINK, ESPECIALLY NOW THAT
WE'RE IN DEFICIT AND WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION THÀNH,
EVERY INVESTMENT HAS GOT TO BE A
MULTIPLIER IN SOME WAY. AND SO,
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT BUILDING A GREEN STEEL
MILL. THIS IS SORT OF THE WORK
OF THE FUTURE. HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT THIS WORKFORCE OF THE
FUTURE IS HIGH ROAD, RIGHT, BUT
ALSO IS CALLING IN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY LEFT
OUT OF THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. SO
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER AS AS WE LOOK AT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE TAX CREDITS,
HOW WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO
TRACK THE MULTIPLICATION EFFECT
OF THESE DOLLARS AND THOSE
HARDEST HIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THANKS THANK YOU,
SENATOR, AND I THINK YOU CAN SEE
A THEME THERE THAT WE COME BACK
TO IN ALL OF THESE HEARINGS, AND
ESPECIALLY IN A CONSTRAINED
SCENARIO. AND, BACK TO THE
QUESTION OF ANALYZING POTENTIAL
SAVINGS HERE. I'M GOING TO GIVE
THE LÀ Þ AN OPPORTUNITY TO, TO
KIND OF CLOSE WITH A LITTLE
BROADER COMMENT ON YOUR ANALYSIS
FOR THE BENEFIT OF EVERYONE
ATTENDING THE HEARING AND THE
COMMITTEE. SO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CERTAINLY, SO, AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE MENTIONED, THERE ARE
ESTIMATES FROM OUR OFFICE THAT
KIND OF PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES ON
POTENTIAL REVENUE GAINS THAT
COULD BE ACHIEVED BY ENACTING
THIS POLICY, TOTAL AND TOTAL
AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ASSUMPTIONS GO INTO
THESE NUMBERS, THE TIMING COULD
BE, YOU KNOW, NOTABLY DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WE HAVE HERE. BUT
HOPEFULLY THIS GIVES YOU A KIND
OF A GENERAL SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE THAT COULD BE ACHIEVED
IN TERMS OF THE REVENUE GAINS,
JUST A COUPLE OF OTHER, COMMENTS
JUST ABOUT THIS CONCEPT
GENERALLY, I THINK THAT THERE'S,
YOU KNOW, THE GÓMEZ MENTIONED
THE KIND OF ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE BEING ABLE
TO AWARD THESE UNUSED FUNDS
PROVIDES THEM, I THINK THERE'S
KIND OF SOME PROS AND CONS TO
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY MENTIONED
SOME OF THE PROS THAT
POTENTIALLY ALLOWS THEM TO OFFER
LARGER AWARDS TO ATTRACT BIGGER
PROJECTS, IT IT GIVES THEM A
BIGGER POOL OF FUNDS TO,
CONTINUE TO AWARD PAST 180 IF
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL, GOOD
APPLICANTS BEFORE THEM, ON THE
OTHER HAND, THOUGH, THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THOSE
PARAMETERS AND LAW FOR A REASON.
YOU KNOW, THEY SET THE 180IN
STATUTE FOR A REASON. THEY SAID
THAT THERE WAS A MAXIMUM, YOU
KNOW, ANNUAL AMOUNT THAT COULD
GO TO ANY ONE AWARDEE FOR A
REASON, THERE MAY BE REASONS TO
DISCUSS CHANGING THOSE, BUT
THAT'S PROBABLY A DISCUSSION
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE, IN A KIND OF
EXPLICIT WAY, YOU KNOW, AND ONE,
ONE FINAL SORT OF CONSIDERATION
IS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED A NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
THERE IS SOME RESEARCH ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS PROGRAM. I
THINK ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
MECHANISMS THAT THAT
EFFECTIVENESS IS BELIEVED TO BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH IS SORT OF THE
COMPETITIVE NATURE OF THE
PROGRAM, THE FACT THAT NOT
EVERYONE WHO APPLIES GETS IT,
THAT THERE IS THIS COMPETITIVE,
RIGOROUS PROCESS, AND THE LARGER
THE POOL IS IN ANY GIVEN YEAR,
SORT OF THE LESS COMPETITION
THERE WILL BE TO GET THOSE
CREDITS. AND SO YOU COULD BE IN
SOME TO SOME EXTENT BLUNTING
THAT THAT MECHANISM, IF THE POOL
BECOMES TOO LARGE, I APPRECIATE
THAT. ANY QUESTIONS FOR LAL? ALL
RIGHT. I WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW,
I'M CERTAINLY NOT A PERSON
WITHOUT OPINIONS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL WORK. THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD DO ON THE ON ON TUNING UP
THIS PROGRAM TO BE MUCH MORE
INTEGRATED AND STRATEGIC. BUT
THAT SAID, I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATIONS ON THE POTENTIAL
REVENUE GAINS HERE AND WITH
THAT, THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN. WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM ISSUE
14, WHICH IS RECAPITALIZATION OF
BANKS REVOLVING FUND. THOSE
FOLKS COME FORWARD, MAKE
YOURSELVES COMFORTABLE. AND
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. RIGHT
GOOD MORNING. I'M CLINT KELLUM.
I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK, OR I BANK. I
BANK IS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, AND WE SERVE AS THE
STATE'S ONLY GENERAL PURPOSE
FINANCING AUTHORITY. OUR MISSION
IS TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA. WE DO
THIS IN ALIGNMENT WITH OUR THREE
TOP PRIORITIES CREATING JOBS,
ENSURING INCLUSIVITY INTO OUR
PROGRAMS, AND ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE. STAFF DID A NICE JOB
SUMMARIZING OUR PROPOSAL ON THE
AGENDA, AND I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION TO SUPPLEMENT THAT.
ONE OF THE BANK'S FLAGSHIP
FINANCING PROGRAMS IS OUR
MUNICIPAL LENDING PROGRAM, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STATE REVOLVING
FUND. IT WAS ESTABLISHED 25
YEARS AGO AND RECEIVED INITIAL
STATE FUNDING OF $162 MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. THIS HAS
BEEN THE STATE'S ONLY INVESTMENT
IN THE PROGRAM TO DATE, AND IT
REMAINS AN ASSET TO THE STATE BY
SUPPORTING CURRENTLY OUTSTANDING
MUNICIPAL LOAN PORTFOLIO OF $530
MILLION, AND WILL EVOLVE TO
SUPPORT PROJECTS WELL INTO THE
FUTURE. THE IMPORTANCE OF
FINANCING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
UNDENIABLE, AND EYE BANK'S
INFRASTRUCTURE LOAN PROGRAM
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING MUNICIPALITIES AND A
RANGE OF CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS, RANGING FROM WATER,
SEWER, TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY
. SINCE THE PROGRAM'S INCEPTION,
WE FUNDED 146 INFRASTRUCTURE
LOANS ACROSS THE STATE,
PRIMARILY TO CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
AND MEDIUM SIZED CITIES,
COUNTIES, AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
TO FINANCE PROJECTS RANGING FROM
ROADS AND MUNICIPAL UTILITIES TO
PORT FACILITIES AND AIRPORTS.
THE AVERAGE SIZE OF THE LOAN IS
AROUND $7 MILLION. OUR SMALLEST
IS ABOUT 500,000 AND OUR LARGEST
IS 40 MILLION. IN THE LAST 25
YEARS, I BANK HAS LEVERAGED THE
INITIAL $162 MILLION. THE STATE
PROVIDED SIX TIMES TO FINANCE
MORE THAN 1 BILLION IN MUNICIPAL
INFRASTRUCTURE LOANS. NOW, 25
YEARS LATER, SUCCESS HAS LED TO
THE POINT WHERE OUR PROGRAM IS
APPROACHING THE LIMITS OF
AVAILABLE LEVERAGE FROM THE
ORIGINAL GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION. CONSEQUENTLY, THE
BANK IS REQUESTING THAT THE
STATE MAKE ITS SECOND INVESTMENT
INTO THE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM WITH
A $50 MILLION, ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION IN 2425. TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THESE PROJECTS
AT AFFORDABLE INTEREST RATES FOR
THOSE MUNICIPALITIES THAT ARE
UNABLE TO SELF-FUND THEIR
PROJECTS AND UNABLE TO ACCESS
THE BOND MARKETS THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS LEÓN DÍAS,
SO, OUR OVERARCHING COMMENTS ON
THIS ARE PRETTY SIMILAR TO THE
COMPETES GRANTS THAT, YOU KNOW,
IN LIGHT OF THE STATE'S BROADER
BUDGET SITUATION, WE RECOMMEND
AGAINST APPROVING THIS FUNDING.
THE PROPOSAL IS NOT WITHOUT
POTENTIAL MERITS, BUT THERE'S A
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THEY
KIND OF REACH A CRITICAL
THRESHOLD GIVEN THE BUDGET
ENVIRONMENT, OUR READ OF THE
SITUATION IS THAT, THE KIND OF
THE CONSEQUENCE OF NOT
ALLOCATING THIS FUNDING IS THAT,
THE PROGRAM WOULD ESSENTIALLY,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF OPERATE UNDER
SUBOPTIMAL TERMS. THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO KIND OF INCREASE THE
INTEREST RATES OR OTHER KIND OF
LENDING COSTS FOR THEIR, THEIR
PARTNERS, THE BONDS THAT THEY
ISSUE TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM,
MAY CARRY HIGHER RATES
THEMSELVES, THESE ARE, YOU KNOW,
NO DOUBT THESE ARE THESE ARE
CONSEQUENCES, YOU KNOW, REAL
CONSEQUENCES, IT'S JUST A
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT YOU
KNOW, HOW THEY'LL STACK UP
AGAINST THE OTHER KINDS OF
CONSIDERATIONS YOU'RE MAKING IN
THE BROADER BUDGET PICTURE IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YEAH.
CHARLES SAU, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, I'LL JUST REITERATE MY,
COMMENTS FOR MY COLLEAGUE AT EYE
BANK, WE FEEL THAT THESE FUNDS
ARE NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN THE
CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS OF THE
SRF, AND CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
LOANS AT PREFERRED INTEREST
RATES TO LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES.
ALL RIGHT. AND JUST STAYING
THERE WITH YOU, I'LL BRING IT TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. AND FOR EITHER
ONE OF YOU, BUT OBVIOUSLY THEY
IDENTIFY ANALYZE RISK HERE IS
MAYBE ON THE BOND RATING SIDE,
ON WITH THE PASSAGE OF TIME, CAN
YOU ADDRESS THE SUGGESTIONS
ABOUT A FREEZE IN LENDING
ACTIVITIES TEMPORARILY IMPACT ON
THE RATING, POTENTIALLY. AND
THEN THE SUFFICIENCY OF OTHER,
BOND, OTHER BONDING OR SPECIAL
DISTRICT OR OTHER TYPES OF
FINANCING MECHANISMS THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHEN IT COMES TO INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING. IN OTHER WORDS, WHO
DOES THIS SERVE THAT CAN'T GET
ANYTHING ANYWHERE ELSE? TO PUT
IT IN LAYMAN'S LANGUAGE, AND IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THOSE POINTS,
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT. YEAH.
GOOD. GOOD QUESTION. SO ON THE
FIRST PIECE, THE RELATED TO THE
IMMEDIATE EFFECTS HERE, IT'S NOT
A BINARY CHANGE AND I CAN'T
COMMENT WITH ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY
HERE BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS SORT
OF CHANGING DYNAMICS IN SORT OF
OUR FUNDING, THE BOND MARKETS
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING. WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THAT OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, IF YOU LOOK AT
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING, IT'S
BEEN HARD HIT FROM INFLATIONARY
COSTS, INTEREST RATES MORE THAN
DOUBLING, NOT GETTING THIS
PROPOSAL HAS THE LIKELY EFFECT
OF MAKING US ISSUE SMALLER
BONDS. MOST BOND COSTS ARE
FAIRLY FIXED, SO THOSE WILL
BECOME A GREATER PROPORTION AND
LESS ECONOMICAL. THOSE EFFECTS
WOULD BE PASSED DOWN TO OUR
BORROWERS. YOU COULD HAVE LESS
INSTITUTIONAL, BOND PURCHASERS
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN OUR
BONDS, THEREBY INCREASING THE
SPREAD. WHEN WE GO TO THE
MARKET, MAKING THOSE RATES
HIGHER, THEN THERE'S THE ISSUE
OF, DO WE GET TO A POINT AT
WHICH THE STATE'S INVESTMENT IN
RELATION TO OUR DEBT ACTUALLY
DRIVES A CREDIT RATING REDUCTION
, WHICH WOULD THEN FURTHER DRIVE
RATES HIGHER, THE POOL
DIVERSITY. THIS KIND OF SPEAKS
TO YOUR LAST QUESTION TO THE WAY
IT'S STRUCTURED IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE DO HAVE SOME BETTER
CREDIT MUNICIPALITIES, LIKE
BIGGER COUNTIES THAT PARTICIPATE
, USUALLY BECAUSE IT'S A SMALLER
AMOUNT THAN IS EFFECTIVE. IF
THEY WENT TO THE BOND MARKET.
THOSE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
OUR LOAN POOL DIVERSITY, BECAUSE
THEY INCREASE THE CREDIT OF THE
PORTFOLIO AND THAT ALLOWS US TO
BE ABLE TO ISSUE LOANS TO THE
UNRATED OR LOWER END BORROWERS
THAT WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE BOND MARKET, SO THAT IF THAT
THOSE IF OUR RATES GO HIGHER,
THEY MAY NOT COME TO US ANYMORE,
THEY MIGHT GO DIRECTLY TO THE
BOND MARKETS OR OTHER SOURCES.
AND THAT HAS THE IMPACT OF, YOU
KNOW, FURTHER DEGRADING THE
CREDIT OF THE QUALITY OF THE
PORTFOLIO AND FURTHER, YOU KNOW,
IMPACTING THE UNDERSERVED, SORT
OF, MUNICIPALITIES THAT REALLY
DO NEED OUR FINANCING AS IT
RELATES TO ALTERNATIVES, AGAIN,
I THINK FOLKS ARE FAIRLY AWARE
OF THE ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT. WE
HAD BANK FAILURES FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A LONG TIME, AND A
SIGNIFICANT MAGNITUDE WITH
INFLATED CREDIT CREDIT, OR
INTEREST RATES. THE SORT OF
CREDIT OFFERINGS BY BANKS ARE
MORE LIMITED. THEY CAN INVEST
RISK FREE AT 5% VERSUS TAKING ON
SLIGHTLY GREATER RISK FOR A
SMALLER RETURN, AND SO THAT
THOSE CREDIT CRUNCHES ARE MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
MUNICIPALITIES TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS ALTERNATIVE FINANCING
SOURCES. AND REALLY, THE BREAD
AND BUTTER OF THESE SMALLER AND
MEDIUM SIZED MUNICIPALITIES,
THEY JUST DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
SORT OF MEANS OR COMPLEXITY TO
GO DIRECTLY TO THE BOND MARKET.
SO THEIR ALTERNATIVES ARE KIND
OF LIMITED RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
AND THAT'S REALLY ONE OF THE
MAIN PURPOSES WE SERVE WITH OUR
PROGRAM. MR. COMMENT. ALL RIGHT.
IF NOT, I'LL BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
SENATOR NILO. WE CAN TALK A LOT
ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAMS AND I DON'T QUESTION
THEIR EFFICACY, BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES ITEMS AND
THESE, I'M GOING TO START TO
SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD HERE.
AND BY THE WAY, I SAID THAT ON
THE FLOOR A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
IN JOHN LAIRD, ONE OF MY FELLOW
ELDER MEMBERS OF THE INSTITUTION
WALKED UP TO ME AND HE SAID, YOU
KNOW, PROBABLY 80% OF THE PEOPLE
HERE DON'T KNOW WHAT A BROKEN
RECORD IS, SO IT JUST MEANS
REPEATING MYSELF. BUT AS THE
STAFF POINTS OUT HERE, MEASURED
AGAINST OTHER PRESSING DEMANDS
FOR BASIC HEALTH, HOUSING AND
HUMAN SERVICES NEEDS, IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PRIORITIZE A MORE
INDIRECTLY BENEFICIAL BUDGET
ITEM. AND JUST BY ONE EXAMPLE,
WE ARE DEFERRING, VERY IMPORTANT
SERVICES TO THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED. NOW IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE THAN THIS, BUT YOU ADD UP
THESE LITTLE NUMBERS AND YOU GET
TO A BIGGER NUMBER, AND IT'S AN
EXPRESSION OF A PRIORITY. SO
WHAT WE'RE KIND OF SAYING IS
THAT THESE EXPENDITURES ARE A
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN DEFERRING,
THE COMPENSATION FOR PEOPLE WHO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO, TO THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. AND I
WOULD ADD THAT IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO END UP MORE THAN A
DEFERRAL GIVEN OVER $30 BILLION
IN DEFICITS BUILT IN IN BUDGET,
BUDGET YEAR SUBSEQUENT TO THIS.
SO SO, AGAIN, I GUESS TO DRAW
UPON AN OLD QUOTE, MAYBE WE JUST
MORE OFTEN NEED TO JUST SAY NO
BECAUSE, WELL, I GUESS I'M GOING
TO SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD
TOO, BUT FOR A DIFFERENT,
DIFFERENT PURPOSE AND REASON.
ONE I'M CURIOUS, CLIENTS, HOW
MANY, MUNICIPALITIES COME TO THE
EYE BANK, JUST JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT. AND THEN, MY OTHER
QUESTION IS, AS WE ARE LOOKING
AGAIN AT, AT, THIS WHOLE NOTION
OF PROCUREMENT IN THE STATE AND
HOW WE HAVE A HIGH ROAD
PROCUREMENT PROCESS AND A SORT
OF A COMPETITION TO THE TOP,
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPETING FOR
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS THAT ACTUALLY
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES. I'M
CURIOUS HOW WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE
DOES THE EYE BANK HAVE FOR THAT,
DO YOU INCENTIVIZE US, FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES AND MAYBE
MUNICIPALITIES THAT HAVE, YOU
KNOW, PLAN AND COMMUNITY
BENEFITS AGREEMENTS AND WHO ARE,
AGAIN, LOOKING AT THESE PRECIOUS
DOLLARS TO DO THE PUBLIC'S WORK,
BUT TO ALSO, AGAIN, SEE IT AS A
MULTIPLIER. I'M CURIOUS HOW THE
HAS THE EYE BANK KIND OF
MODERNIZED AND IN THE WAY THAT
WE ARE LOOKING ACROSS THE STATE
AT THIS QUESTION OF OUR PUBLIC
INVESTMENT AND, AND HOW WE CAN
DO MORE WITH, WITH WHAT WE HAVE.
GREAT, ON THE INITIAL QUESTION,
WE HAVE ABOUT 100 LOANS
OUTSTANDING TODAY. SO IN SOME OF
THOSE ARE MUNICIPALITIES THAT
ARE DUPLICATED. BUT THAT IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD IT GIVES YOU A
SENSE OF ACROSS THE STATE, YOU
KNOW, UP IN SHASTA COUNTY, BUTTE
COUNTY, ALL THE WAY DOWN TO SAN
DIEGO AND ACROSS THE MIDDLE. SO
I THINK IT GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY
IS APPARENT IN OUR OVERALL
PORTFOLIO, AS IT RELATES TO SORT
OF YOUR UNDERLYING QUESTIONS
HERE, THE PROGRAMS, ALL OF OUR
PROJECTS DO HAVE TO BE COMPLETED
WITH THE PREVAILING WAGE IN THE
STATE REQUIREMENT. SO C  SPEAKS
TO THAT. AND AS IT RELATES TO
SORT OF THE UNDERSERVED, YOU
KNOW, MUNICIPALITIES AND HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT THOSE, WE DO OFFER,
UP TO 25 BASIS POINT, INTEREST
RATE SUBSIDIES FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT MEET CERTAIN SOCIOECONOMIC
THRESHOLDS, AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL, UP TO 25
BASIS POINT, REDUCTION FOR SORT
OF CLIMATE ORIENTED PROJECTS
THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS, BUT IF I
COULD MAKE ONE COMMENT TO ON THE
MATTER OF TIMING HERE, I THINK I
WAS ASKED THIS ACTUALLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE, AND WE'VE
WE RECEIVED THESE FUNDS, YOU
KNOW, 25 YEARS AGO, AND WE BUILT
THE PROGRAM AND WE'VE REVOLVED
IT AND WE'VE MONITOR IT. AND
WE'RE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY NOT
BECAUSE IT'S AN OPTIMAL TIME TO
BE REQUESTING MONEY, BUT BECAUSE
THAT'S THE AMOUNT WE FEEL LIKE
WE NEED TO SUSTAIN THE PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL OVER THE
TIME. I ACTUALLY SPENT TEN YEARS
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRIOR TO MY CURRENT
EMPLOYMENT AT EYE BANK, AND I
THINK MY FOLKS WOULD SAY I
SHOULD HAVE TIMED THIS A LITTLE
BIT BETTER FOR US. BUT YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE WE'RE HERE
BEFORE YOU BECAUSE WE THINK THIS
IS ACTUALLY REQUESTED FUNDS THAT
WE NEED. AND AND I, YOU KNOW,
UNFORTUNATELY, THE TIMING IS NOT
GREAT. AND I GUESS I'M THE
QUESTION. SO YOU'RE SAYING THERE
ARE SPECIAL PROGRAMS FOR,
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THEN THERE ARE DID YOU SAY TAX
REDUCTIONS? WHAT? CAN YOU REPEAT
THAT? YEAH. WE SO WHEN WE LOOK
AT A MUNICIPALITY AND WE GO TO
APPROVE A LOAN, WE'RE ALSO
APPROVING AN INTEREST RATE, AND
THAT INTEREST RATE ON AT A BASE
LEVEL IS BASED ON SORT OF THE
CREDIT QUALITY OF THE
MUNICIPALITY. SO, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S THE CREDIT RATING
AGENCIES HAVE THESE SORT OF
STANDARDS, AND YOU WOULD SORT OF
BUCKET IT INTO ONE OF THOSE
STANDARDS. BUT THEN ALSO WE LOOK
AT THE MUNICIPALITY AND SEE IF
IT IS SORT OF HAS SOCIOECONOMIC
FACTORS THAT WOULD CATEGORIZE IT
AS DISADVANTAGED. AND THEN FROM
THERE WE WOULD ACTUALLY LOWER
THE INTEREST RATE UP TO 25 BASIS
POINTS. THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT
. THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS,
WE'LL MOVE TO ISSUE, 15, WHICH
IS A PARTIAL DELAY OF DOWNTOWN
FRESNO'S INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
NEVER HEARD OF THAT PART OF THE
BUDGET BEFORE. OKAY COME ON UP.
MAKE YOURSELF COMFORTABLE.
PROCEED WHEN READY. PERFECT,
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR PADILLA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
LAUREN GREENWOOD, AND I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION
AND INTERGOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS AT
GO-BIZ. THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON THE FUNDING FOR DOWNTOWN
FRESNO INFRASTRUCTURE. AS
MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA, THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY 2024 BUDGET
MAINTAINS 250 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN, BUT PROPOSES TO DELAY
DISBURSEMENT OF 100 MILLION OF
THIS AMOUNT BY ONE YEAR. GO-BIZ
HAS ISSUED 50 MILLION TO FRESNO
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE 2023
BUDGET. THE FUNDING FOR FRESNO
SERVES AS A CATALYST IN DOWNTOWN
FRESNO CHINATOWN AND WILL
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF ITS
POPULATION FROM 3000 TO 10,000
RESIDENTS. THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT LEVERAGES OTHERS, HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTFUL AS IT
RELATES TO HOUSING.
SPECIFICALLY, THE FOOTPRINT FOR
THE INVESTMENT IS ALREADY ZONED
FOR UP TO 15 STORIES. ANY
DENSITY OR LOT COVERAGE IS
ALLOWED. THERE'S A 100 DAY
ENTITLEMENT TIMELINE AND NO
ADDITIONAL CEQA REVIEW IS
REQUIRED. DOWNTOWN FRESNO HAS A
ZONE CAPACITY OF NEARLY 75,000
HOUSING UNITS. FRESNO HAS. THE
INITIAL INVESTMENT PUT THE
INITIAL INVESTMENT TO WORK
THROUGH VARIOUS PROJECTS, SUCH
AS THE ENHANCEMENT OF WATER
DISTRIBUTION AND WASTEWATER
SYSTEMS, FINALIZING SITE CONTROL
AND DEMOLITION OF Kò PROPERTIES
IN CHINATOWN, AND ACTIVATING
OTHER PRE-CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITY
AND ALL FUNDING FUNDING PILLARS
TO ENSURE THESE PROJECTS ARE
SHOVEL READY BY THE 2025 FISCAL
YEAR, EXTENSIVE PREPARATORY
WORK, INCLUDING FEASIBILITY
STUDIES AND DESIGN SERVICES, ARE
UNDERWAY. FRESNO IS MANAGING THE
DELAY IN FUNDING, BUT FURTHER
DELAYS OR REDUCTIONS IN FUNDING
COULD DISRUPT THE TRANSITION
FROM PRE-CONSTRUCTION TO
CONSTRUCTION PHASES, POTENTIALLY
INFLATING COSTS DUE TO EXTENDED
TIMELINES AND INFLATION. FRESNO
LAUNCHED A NEW CITY DEPARTMENT
TO HAVE STAFF WORKING AS A
STRIKE TEAM TO ENSURE EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE DELIVERY OF LARGE
SCALE CAPITAL PROGRAM PROJECTS.
ADDITIONAL DELAYS COULD IMPACT
THE STRUCTURE, WHICH HAS TAKEN
TIME TO TRANSITION AND EXPAND.
LASTLY, WE NOTE FOR DECADES THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY HAS
POINTED TO THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INABILITY TO
FINANCE HOUSING WITHOUT NEEDING
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING GAP FUNDS,
RESULTING IN VACANCY AND EMPTY
LOTS. WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
CITY'S BROADER URBAN DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGY, AIMED AT FOSTERING A
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING FOR
DOWNTOWN. THESE 20 2526 FUNDS
ARE ESSENTIAL TO CAPITALIZE ON
THE GROUNDWORK LAID DURING THIS
LAST YEAR, ENSURING THAT
PROJECTS ARE NOT ONLY ON
SCHEDULE, BUT ALSO COST
EFFECTIVE, AND ALIGN WITH THE
CITY'S STRATEGIC URBAN RENEWAL
GOALS. THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
COMMENT, YEAH. JUST JUST BRIEFLY
, I THINK AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION HERE IS GIVEN SORT
OF THE MULTI YEAR OUTLOOK FOR
THE BUDGET, WHILE THESE FUNDS
ARE CURRENTLY SLATED FOR DELAY,
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT RISK THAT
WHEN WE GET TO NEXT YEAR, THE
RESOURCES MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT THE ALLOCATION IN
2526. YEAH. CHARLES SAU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
SPENDING PLAN, A GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ONLY INCLUDES A DELAY OF
THE RESOURCES SUPPORTING THE
FRESNO INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
BECAUSE IT WAS NECESSARY TO
CLOSE A PROJECTED BUDGET
SHORTFALL, THIS DELAY WAS PART
OF A BROADER STRATEGY, INCLUSIVE
OF REDUCTIONS AND OTHER DELAYS.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT THIS WAS ONLY
PROPOSED AS A DELAY, BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
VALUE OF THE INVESTMENT AND THE
POSITIVE BENEFITS OF SUPPORTING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
THE CITY OF FRESNO. ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW THE OBVIOUS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THE OBVIOUS QUESTIONS
ARE EVEN WITH A DELAY IN
ALLOCATION, THERE MAY BE
INCREMENTAL COST IMPACTS, TOTAL
PROJECT COST IMPACTS, COST IN
JOBS. THE OBVIOUS. AND THEN THE
OTHER OBVIOUS QUESTION, I THINK
WHETHER IT COMES FROM ME OR ANY
OTHER MEMBER IS, YOU KNOW, WHY
JUST THIS APPROACH OR HAS THERE
BEEN SERIOUS CONSIDERATION GIVEN
TO, TO WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT
OF NO FURTHER FUNDING, ON THIS
ON THE GROUND? I MEAN, I
UNDERSTAND WHAT FRESNO HAS BEEN
DOING FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS, AND
IT'S A GREAT PLAN. IT'S A GREAT
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECT.
IT'S GREAT FOR JOBS AND IT'S A
PRIORITY. AND I SUPPORTED IT IN
THE LAST BUDGET CYCLE. BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR A
SERIOUS ANALYSIS OF IT, RIGHT,
TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION. SO IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THOSE TWO
OBVIOUS POINTS, I'D APPRECIATE
IT. AND THEN I'LL BRING IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES. SURE, LAUREN
GREENWOOD WITH GÓMEZ. I THINK
THAT, THERE WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF IMPACT
SHOULD, THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
A FULL REDUCTION OF THE FUNDS?
AND WHAT? I JUST GO BACK TO WHAT
I STATED EARLIER IS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR
75,000 HOUSING UNITS IN AN AREA
THAT'S BEEN UNDER INVESTED OVER
DECADES. AND, SPECIFICALLY
SPEAKING TO THE 250 MILLION,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN INCREASE
OF 7000 OR HOUSING FOR 7000
RESIDENTS, AND THAT WOULD BE
THAT INTERMODAL TRANSIT CENTER.
AND, AND IT WOULD SUPPORT ALL
THE SERVICES THAT DEVELOP,
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT DEVELOPERS
NEED TO CONTINUE TO COMPOUND ON
HOUSING. ALL RIGHT. QUESTIONS,
SENATOR. I WAS GOING TO ASK THE
SAME QUESTION. SO I WON'T REPEAT
THAT, BUT I LOVE FRESNO. IT'S A
GREAT TOWN, HAS SOME THINGS IN
COMMON WITH, MY HOMETOWN,
SACRAMENTO, BUT IS CHALLENGED
AND, IT'S RIGHT THAT THE STATE
FOCUSES ON THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
WHICH HAS CHALLENGES, BUT I
WON'T REPEAT MY STATEMENTS
BEFORE, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
JUST AT THIS POINT, THE STATE
CAN'T AFFORD. BUT HOPEFULLY IN
FUTURE YEARS, WE'LL BE ABLE TO
AGAIN. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT.
THANK YOU. THAT I WON'T BE HELD.
WE WILL MOVE THEN TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. ISSUE 16 IS
CAL ACCESS REPLACEMENT SYSTEM.
THE CARS PROJECT.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME. PLEASE
PROCEED. ONE. READY THANK YOU,
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR PADILLA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS TAMARA JOHNSON, CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER. AND ON BEHALF
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE,
DOCTOR SHIRLEY AND WEBER, I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU HERE TODAY.
BUT FIRST, IF YOU WOULD ALLOW ME
TO GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
AGENCY. SECRETARY WEBER WAS
NOMINATED TO SERVE AS CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE BY GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM ON DECEMBER 22ND,
2020, AND SWORN INTO OFFICE ON
JANUARY 29TH, 2021.
SUBSEQUENTLY, THE VOTERS ELECTED
HER TO A FULL TERM ON NOVEMBER
8TH, 2022. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE IS COMPRISED OF
OVER 600 PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO MAKING GOVERNMENT
MORE TRANSPARENT AND ACCESSIBLE
IN THE AREAS OF ELECTIONS,
BUSINESS, POLITICAL CAMPAIGNING,
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY, ADVOCACY
AND HISTORICAL RECORDS. THE
AGENCY IS COMPRISED OF ALL OF
THE FOLLOWING OPERATIONAL
DIVISIONS ELECTIONS, POLITICAL
REFORM, BUSINESS PROGRAMS,
ARCHIVES, INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY, FISCAL AFFAIRS AND
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDE SERVING
AS THE STATE'S CHIEF ELECTIONS
OFFICER, IMPLEMENTING ELECTRONIC
FILING AND INTERNET DISCLOSURE
OF CAMPAIGN AND LOBBYIST
FINANCIAL INFORMATION,
MAINTAINING BUSINESS FILINGS,
COMMISSIONING NOTARIES PUBLIC,
OPERATING THE SAFE AT HOME
CONFIDENTIAL ADDRESS PROGRAM,
MAINTAINING THE DOMESTIC
PARTNERS AND ADVANCED HEALTH
CARE DIRECTIVE REGISTRIES.
PRESERVING MORE THAN 250 MILLION
RECORDS AND ARTIFACTS HELD IN
THE STATE ARCHIVES AND SERVING
AS A TRUSTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM. THE SECRETARY OF STATE
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES INCLUDE
STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
VOTING ENVIRONMENT, OPTIMIZING
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
FOUNDATION, PROVIDING FULL
EXPOSURE TO THE STATE'S ARCHIVE
COLLECTIONS, AND PROVIDING
TRANSPARENT ACCESS TO PUBLIC
RESOURCES. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE STRIVES TO
PROMOTE INCLUSIVITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY, TO CREATE AN
ELECTION SYSTEM DESIGNED TO
ALLOW CITIZENS TO PERFORM THEIR
MOST BASIC CIVIC DUTY WITH EASE.
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THE AGENCY
HAS OVERSIGHT OF OR ADMINISTERS
TO FURTHER THAT EFFORT IS THE
NEW CITIZENS PROGRAM, THE
MILITARY AND OVERSEAS VOTERS
PROGRAM. THE STUDENT VOTER
REGISTRATION PROGRAM, AND THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS VOTE
PROJECT, WHICH I MIGHT ADD IS A
FIRST OF ITS KIND PARTNERSHIP IN
THE NATION WHERE ALL MAJOR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE SOLIDIFIED
COMMITMENTS TO PARTNER WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AND
ENCOURAGE STUDENT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. EFFORTS TO PROMOTE A
DEMOCRACY THAT IS MORE INCLUSIVE
OF STUDENT VOICES. FURTHERMORE,
THE SECRETARY OF STATE
ADMINISTERS CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM KNOWN
AS VOEPEL, WHICH SERVES AS THE
SINGLE SYSTEM FOR STORING AND
MANAGING THE OFFICIAL LIST OF
REGISTERED VOTERS IN THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S BUSINESS SERVICES ARE
THE FIRST STOP FOR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES TO REGISTER AND BEGIN
THE JOURNEY. BIZ FILE CALIFORNIA
IS SACRIFICED. SACHER IS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S ONLINE
PORTAL TO HELP BUSINESSES FILE
SEARCH AND ORDER BUSINESS
RECORDS QUICKLY AND CONVENIENTLY
FROM A SINGLE LOCATION. THIS
FILE CALIFORNIA ALSO PROVIDES
RESOURCES RELATED TO STARTING A
BUSINESS. TRADEMARKS. UNIFORM
COMMERCIAL CODE FINANCING
STATEMENTS, AND OTHER TAX LIENS
AND IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS.
FINALLY, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S ONGOING OBJECTIVE IS TO
FOSTER TRUST IN OUR DEMOCRACY BY
FACILITATING THE TRANSPARENT AND
ACCURATE DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION, RESOURCES, AND
FINANCES. THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATED LOBBYIST AND CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION AND EXPENDITURE
SEARCH SYSTEM, KNOWN AS CAL
ACCESS, IS THE PUBLIC'S WINDOW
INTO CALIFORNIA'S CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURE AND LOBBYING
FINANCIAL ACTIVITY, PROVIDING
FINANCIAL INFORMATION SUPPLIED
BY STATE CANDIDATES, DONORS,
LOBBYISTS, LOBBYISTS, EMPLOYERS
AND OTHERS. THE CAL ACCESS
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM PROJECT, OR
KNOWN AS THE CARS PROJECT, WILL
IMPLEMENT A NEW DATA DRIVEN
SYSTEM REPLACING THE EXISTING
FORMS DRIVEN SYSTEM THAT
CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW OF THE
AGENCY. AND NOW I WILL QUICKLY
GO TO THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY, THE
FIRST ITEM IS THE CARS PROJECT.
THE OBJECTIVE OF THE CARS
PROJECT IS TO REPLACE THE
OUTDATED CAL ACCESS SYSTEM FOR
ELECTRONIC REPORTING OF CAMPAIGN
FINANCE AND LOBBYING ACTIVITIES
MANDATED BY THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT. THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU WILL
PROVIDE ONE TIME FUNDING OF
16,774,000 GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF THIS
EFFORT. SPECIFICALLY, THE
REQUEST WILL PROVIDE CONTINUED
FUNDING FOR 33 PRIOR APPROVED
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE SECOND
YEAR OF PLANNING ACTIVITIES AND
BACKFILL STAFF RECRUITED TO
SUPPORT ONGOING PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES. AND WE JUST LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE TOTAL CARS PROJECT
COST IN 2425 IS 22,163,000, AND
OF THAT AMOUNT, APPROXIMATELY
5.4 MILLION IS EXISTING IN
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED ONGOING
FUNDING, AND THEN THE REMAINING
16,000,774 IS THE REQUEST BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO COVER THE NEEDED
REMAINING COSTS. WITH ME, TODAY
IS JOHN HIGHLAND, WHO IS THE
ASSISTANT CARS PROJECT DIRECTOR,
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
COMMENT FROM LÀ, NICK SCHROEDER,
NO COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE. GET
THE OFF. I ALSO SAW OUR FINANCE
CLIENTS. ALL RIGHT, OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS A COMPLIANCE ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THE PROGRAM. DO YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON THE
TIMELINES AND NEXT STEPS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION FOR CARS? THE
SALAS IS PROJECTING TO ON BANK
ON. COULD YOU JUST AGAIN STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD AND
MAKE SURE WE CAN GO INTO THAT
MIC, WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT WORK,
BUT GIVE IT A SHOT. MY NAME IS
JOHN HEINLEIN. I'M THE ASSISTANT
CARS PROJECT DIRECTOR. I WORK
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE CARS
PROJECT THE SÐNG IS PROJECTING
TO ON BOARD THE PRIME VENDOR AND
BEGIN DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES IN
SUMMER 2024. GO LIVE OF THE NEW
SOLUTION IS ANTICIPATED TO BE
SHORTLY AFTER THE NOVEMBER 20TH,
2026 ELECTIONS. THIS TIMELINE
ALIGNS WITH OUR ORIGINAL
SCHEDULED ESTIMATE BASED ON THE
THIRD PARTY LEÓN ASSESSMENT, AND
ENSURES THAT WE DON'T CREATE ANY
CONFUSION OR RISKS PRIOR TO THE
2026 GENERAL ELECTION. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS,
SENATOR NEIL? THANK YOU. IF,
THIS ALLOCATION, DOES NOT
SURVIVE THE BUDGET PROCESS, WILL
YOU, BE ABLE TO, REALIGN DUTIES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT TO KEEP
THE PROJECT GOING? WELL, ANY
REDUCTION OF FUNDING OR
DEFERRING OF FUNDING RISKS,
FURTHER DEPENDENCY ON THE LEGACY
CAL ACCESS, WHICH, YOU KNOW,
RISKS OUTAGES AND SIGNIFICANT
LOSS OF SERVICES TO CAL ACCESS
USERS, INCLUDING THEIR ABILITY
TO SUBMIT STATE MANDATED FILINGS
AND REPORTS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
ADDITIONALLY, IF THE CAR'S
FUNDING WAS DEFERRED, THE CAR'S
PLANNING ACTIVITIES WOULD BE
DELAYED BY 12 MONTHS, WHICH
WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM IMPLEMENTATION DATE
BEING EXTENDED BY 18 MONTHS OR
MORE. THE DELAY WOULD ALSO
INCREASE THE PROJECT'S OVERALL
COST BY SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS.
BASED ON THE ESTIMATED PROJECT
BUDGET. WITHOUT THE NECESSARY
FUNDING, THE PROJECT WOULD HAVE
TO TERMINATE CRITICAL CONSULTANT
CONTRACTS, WHICH WOULD HAVE TO
BE PROCURED WHEN THE FUNDING IS
REINSTATED, WHICH WOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO A LOSS OF TIME AND
A LOSS OF MOMENTUM CAUSED BY
PAUSING ALL PROJECT ACTIVITIES.
I HAVE A FEELING YOU ANTICIPATED
THAT QUESTION. YEAH, WE DID. I
JUST PUT THAT IN ALONG WITH
OTHER PRIORITIES OF OUR BUDGET
THAT I'VE SAID IS PRETTY
CHALLENGED, SENATOR. ALL RIGHT.
THAT WILL BE HELD OPEN. ITEM 17
IS AN ARP 2.0. YES, SIR. THANK
YOU, THE NOTARY AUTOMATION
PROGRAM REPLACED PROJECT, OR
ALSO KNOWN AS NAP 2.0, JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON ON
THE SYSTEM. THE SYSTEM IS
APPROXIMATELY 30 YEARS OLD. IT
WAS DEVELOPED UTILIZING AN
APPLICATION THAT IN PRESENT DAY
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
UPDATE AND TO FIND QUALIFIED
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY STAFF OR
VENDORS TO SUPPORT THE
APPLICATION, CURRENT TECHNOLOGY
HAS EVOLVED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE
THE SYSTEM WAS CREATED, THUS
INTEGRATION OF THE LEGACY SYSTEM
WITH CURRENT AND FUTURE
TECHNOLOGY AND POSSIBLE A THIRD,
POSSIBLY A THIRD PARTY. A THIRD
PARTY SYSTEMS WILL BE
CHALLENGING, THE REQUEST BEFORE
YOU TODAY IS FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING OF 4,018,000 FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THE PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT, I WILL NOTE, IS
SUPPORTED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S BUSINESS FEES FUND, THE
TOTAL PROJECT COSTS IN 2425 IS
5,738,000. OF THAT AMOUNT
1,004,077 IS FOR SIX NEW
POSITIONS AND CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR TWO EXISTING POSITIONS,
WHICH WERE APPROVED IN 2324,
800,000 IS FOR CONTINUING VENDOR
AND NEW VENDOR CONTRACTS, COSTS,
EXCUSE ME, AND 325,000 FOR
PLANNING RESOURCES. THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY ABOUT 890,000 FOR
K¾T AND DGS SERVICES AND FEES,
AND THEN 528,000 FOR TEMPORARY
STAFF TO BACKFILL STAFF
POSITIONS REDIRECTED TO THE
PROJECT. AND THEN THE REMAINING
1.72 MILLION WILL BE FUNDED
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES, WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE ED LACROIX, WHO
IS THE CHIEF APPLICATION OFFICER
FOR THE PROJECT. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. QUESTIONS FROM
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. SENATOR NEIL.
SO, THIS IS, FUNDED BY FEES PAID
BY BUSINESSES. WHAT'S THEIR
POSITION WITH REGARD TO THE
SPENDING AND THE PROGRAM? DO
THEY FORMALLY SUPPORT THIS? I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK SHANNON
DELGADO TO COME TO THE TABLE.
SHE IS THE ASSISTANT CHIEF
BUSINESS ASSISTANT CHIEF OF THE
BUSINESS PROGRAMS DIVISION.
SHE'LL BE ABLE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FOR YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR. I'M SHANNON
DELGADO, ASSISTANT CHIEF OF THE
BUSINESS PROGRAMS DIVISION OF
THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE. SO WE HAVE NOT
FORMALLY SOLICITED FEEDBACK FROM
THOSE THAT PAY TOWARDS THE
BUSINESS FEES, FUNDS FOR THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE,
HOWEVER. SO WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT
BACK AND GET YOU BETTER
INFORMATION. WE CAN WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE MORE
TANGIBLE INFORMATION RELATED TO
THAT. I WILL SAY THE SYSTEM, AS
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED, IS
ALMOST 30 YEARS OLD, AND THE
NOTARY COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS DEFINITELY THEY
HAVE EXPRESSED THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR INNOVATION, MORE
SERVICES, ONLINE FUNCTIONALITY.
AND SO WE DO SEE THAT WE HAVE A
DUTY TO PROVIDE IMPROVEMENTS TO
THAT COMMUNITY WITHIN THE STATE,
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 147,000 NOTARIES
IN OUR STATE TODAY, IN TERMS OF
CONCLUDING THE BUDGET PROCESS,
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW THE
SUPPORT BY THOSE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY PAYING FOR IT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT,
ANYTHING ELSE, THEN THAT ITEM IS
HELD OPEN. WE WILL THEN MOVE TO
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ISSUE 18 IS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR BANKING
OPERATIONS, ITEM PROCESSING,
SOFTWARE, SERVICE
.
WELCOME. AND WE'LL GIVE
EVERYBODY A MINUTE TO SORT OF
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM. CAN
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR PADILLA.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
NATALIE GONZALEZ, ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRALIZED
TREASURY AND SECURITIES
MANAGEMENT DIVISION, OR CSD, AT
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE. AND WITH
ME, I HAVE THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY DIVISION,
NHIÀU MOHAMMED, TO GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND ON OUR PROGRAM. IT'S
THE PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY OF
CSD TO OVERSEE ALL BANKING
ASPECTS OF THE CENTRALIZED
TREASURY SYSTEM. OUR GOAL IS TO
MAXIMIZE THE EARNING OF
INTEREST, CONSISTENT WITH SAFE
AND PRUDENT TREASURY MANAGEMENT,
AND TO ENSURE THAT OUR
DEPOSITORY BANKS PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH PROPER AND ADEQUATE
SECURITY FOR THE DEPOSIT OF
STATE MONIES ON A DAILY BASIS.
WE MANAGE THE CASH LIQUIDITY
NEEDS OF ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AND ENSURE THAT ALL
IDLE STATE FUNDS ARE INVESTED TO
MEET THESE GOALS. SOME OF THE
CORE FUNCTIONS OF K¾T THAT CSD
PERFORMS ARE. PREPARE FORECASTS
OF REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES,
WHICH WE USE TO DETERMINE THE
AMOUNTS AVAILABLE FOR DAILY
INVESTMENTS. WE ENSURE BANKS
PROVIDE THE STATE ACCURATE AND
TIMELY AGENCY DEPOSITS,
ADMINISTER AND EXECUTE THE WIRE
TRANSFER OF FUNDS, RECONCILE
STATE ACCOUNTS WITH DEPOSITORY
BANK ACCOUNTS, AND WE REDEEM ALL
STATE ISSUED ITEMS SUBMITTED BY
PRESENTING BANKS FOR PAYMENT.
THE CSD IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
EXECUTING THE CLEARANCE AND
INCOME COLLECTION FOR STATE
INVESTMENTS AND SECURITIES
PLEDGED TO THE STATE, EXCLUDING
PERSONAL INVESTMENTS. THE
CLEARANCE AND SETTLEMENT OF
SECURITIES PLEDGES COLLATERAL TO
THE STATE FOR THE TIME DEPOSIT,
DEMAND DEPOSIT AND OTHER AGENCY
PROGRAMS AND WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SAFEKEEPING OF
SECURITIES AND OTHER PROPERTY
OWNED BY OR PLEDGED TO THE STATE
. SO BEFORE YOU TODAY, WE HAVE
TWO REQUESTS. OUR FIRST REQUEST
IS FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING DUE TO
INCREASED COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE USE AND SUPPORT OF THE FIS
IMAGE VISION ITEM PROCESSING
SOFTWARE. THIS SOFTWARE IS USED
TO FACILITATE THE STATE'S DAILY
CHECK PROCESSING ACTIVITIES,
WHICH ALLOW US TO MAKE PAY OR NO
PAY DECISIONS ON STATE ISSUED
CHECKS AND WARRANTS PRESENTED
FOR PAYMENT. THE COST INCREASES
DUE PRIMARILY TO THE SHIFT FROM
AN ON PREMISES LEGACY FRAMEWORK,
WHICH WILL NO LONGER BE
SUPPORTED BY THE VENDOR TO A
CLOUD BASED ARCHITECTURE, AND
THE CHANGE FROM A FLAT RATE
BILLING MODEL TO A VOLUME BASED
BILLING MODEL. THIS UPGRADE WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE SERVICING
THE NEEDS OF ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS. OUR SECOND REQUEST
IS FOR BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE,
WHICH WILL MITIGATE THE
CHALLENGES THE STATE HAS
ENCOUNTERED WITH NEWER DGS
PURCHASING REQUIREMENTS, AND IT
WILL ENSURE THAT VENDOR
ASSOCIATED PROCUREMENTS RELATED
TO THE TREASURER'S
CONSTITUTIONAL AND LEGISLATIVE
BANKING AND INVESTMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES WILL CONTINUE
UNINTERRUPTED. THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE WAS AGREED UPON WITH
DGS AND IS LIMITED TO A TWO YEAR
PERIOD. DGS HAS INDICATED THAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON A STATEWIDE
SOLUTION FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROCUREMENTS, WHICH SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED WITHIN THE TWO YEAR
TIME FRAME. WE'VE REQUESTED. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF OUR REQUESTS,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL BRING IT TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS?
SENATOR NILO? ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN.
THEN WE MOVE TO CALL ISSUE 19,
ADMINISTRATION OF CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVING A BETTER LIFE
EXPERIENCE ACT BOND. THAT'S A
MOUTHFUL. THERE'S GOT TO BE AN
ACCURATE. THERE HAS TO BE FOR
EVERYTHING WE DO. WELCOME. MAKE
YOURSELVES COMFORTABLE. PROCEED.
ONE. READY SURE. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS THOMAS MARTIN. I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CAL ABLE.
AND YES, IT IS A MOUTHFUL, HENCE
THE ACRONYM WITH ME IS ANNE
OSBORNE, THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, SO VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT
WHAT CAL ABLE IS BEFORE GETTING
INTO THE VCP, CAL ABLE IS A
SAVINGS AND INVESTMENT PLAN, TO
BE ELIGIBLE, THE BENEFICIARY HAS
TO HAVE A DISABILITY FROM THAT.
THAT BEGAN BEFORE THE AGE OF 26,
ALTHOUGH THAT'S GOING TO BE
INCREASING TO 46 IN AT THE
BEGINNING OF 2026, AND SO THIS
THIS PROVIDES TWO MAJOR
BENEFITS. ONE IS THAT ANY, ANY
EARNINGS ON, ON THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE EXEMPT FROM
TAXES PROVIDED THEY'RE USED FOR,
QUALIFIED EXPENSES, WHICH ARE
PRETTY BAD, THOSE EXPENSES CAN
BE ANYTHING RELATED TO HOUSING
OR HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION,
REALLY ANY, ANY SORT OF QUALITY
OF LIFE IMPROVEMENTS. IT'S A
PRETTY BROAD CATEGORY, THE
SECOND MAIN BENEFIT THAT THAT
THIS PROVIDES IS IT ALLOWS IT'S
EXEMPT FROM, MEANS TESTING FOR
STATE AND FEDERAL BENEFITS,
WITHIN FEDERAL LIMITS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, FOR SOCIAL SECURITY, IF
YOU'RE, THE REQUIREMENT COULD BE
THAT YOU, YOU CAN'T HAVE MORE
THAN $2,000 IN ASSETS. BUT THAT
DOESN'T COUNT FOR, FOR WITHIN
THE CAL BEALL ACCOUNT, SO THIS
IS THIS THIS ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY AND PURCHASE
, PURCHASE THINGS LIKE
WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE VEHICLES
OR SERVICE DOGS OR FIRST AND
LAST MONTH RENT AND NO PERMITS,
SO THEY CAN LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
YOU KNOW, MAJOR THINGS THAT ARE
PRETTY CLOSE TO IMPOSSIBLE TO,
TO, TO DO IF YOU CAN ONLY HAVE
$2,000 AT A TIME. SO IT'S, IT'S
A, IT'S A HUGE PROGRAM. IT'S A
GAME CHANGER FOR, FOR THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES, RIGHT NOW WE HAVE,
WE HAVE A LITTLE OVER 11,000
BENEFICIARIES, WITH ACCOUNTS IN
OUR PROGRAM. SO QUITE A FEW
PEOPLE, QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
RECEIVING THE BENEFIT OF THE
PROGRAM NOW TO, TO GET THE
PROGRAM STARTED, AS, AS SOME
KIND OF SEED FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM, KELLY WAS RECEIVED
$4.82 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
LOANS, AND THAT'S WHAT BRINGS US
TO THE BCC BEFORE YOU, SO THE
CCP WOULD, WOULD EXTEND THE
REPAYMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE LOANS
TO 2032, AND IT WOULD WAIVE
INTEREST ON THOSE LOANS. SO THIS
SO, IN THE MEANTIME, KELLY WOULD
MAKE A $1.2 MILLION PAYMENT.
NEXT YEAR AND THEN WOULD MAKE
SUBSEQUENT PAYMENTS EACH YEAR
THEREAFTER, DEPENDING ON THE,
THE, THE REVENUE COMING IN, SO
WITH THAT, I, I APPRECIATE YOUR,
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL, ER,
FOR THE CCP AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, LEO. BRIAN, WITH
THE LÀ, WE HAVE NO COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GREG BRUCE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND NO FURTHER COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A NOTATION IN THE REPORT
THAT THE REPAYMENT WILL COME
FROM A BALANCE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS, CAN YOU
EXPOUND ON THE BALANCE AND HOW
IT'S AVAILABLE, SURE. DO YOU
WANT TO TAKE THAT ONE? YES OKAY,
YES. MY NAME IS ANNE OSBORNE.
I'M THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT CAL POLY, CURRENTLY,
WE HAVE OVER 800,000 IN OUR,
TRUST FUND. AND WE HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING FUNDS SINCE THE
PROGRAM OPENED IN 2018. AND SO,
SO ALL OUR ACCOUNT HOLDERS ARE
CHARGED AS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE. IT'S ON 28 BASIS POINTS.
AND THAT'S BASED ON THE BALANCE
OF THE ACCOUNT. AND SO AS OUR,
OUR, ACCOUNT HOLDERS, THEY ARE
HELPING US, ACQUIRE FUNDS SO WE
CAN MAKE OUR LOAN REPAYMENTS.
THANK YOU. SENATOR NEAL. ANY
QUESTIONS? ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WE'LL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN. MOVE
ON TO, CALSAVERS RETIREMENT
SAVINGS BOARD ISSUE 20. WELCOME.
AND PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DAVID
TAKATA. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CAL SAVERS, OUR
REQUEST TODAY IS FOR $12
MILLION, DRAWN DOWN IN $2
MILLION INCREMENTS OVER THE NEXT
SIX YEARS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO ROLL OUT THE CAL
SAVERS PROGRAM, CAL SAVERS,
FORMERLY KNOWN AS SECURE CHOICE.
TO THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR A WHILE, IS A FIRST
OF ITS KIND PROGRAM THAT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW IN 2016 AND
OFFICIALLY ROLLED OUT IN 2019.
CAL SAVERS EXIST TO ADDRESS THE
STARK REALITY THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT ON TRACK
FOR A SECURE RETIREMENT. HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE ON A TRAJECTORY
FOR FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IN
RETIREMENT. AND THE AND THE
PROBLEM REALLY COMPOUNDS FOR
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED GROUPS
. THE ESSENTIAL PREMISE OF OUR
PROGRAM IS THAT WORKERS ARE 15
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO SAVE FOR
RETIREMENT IF THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO A SAVINGS AND INVESTMENT
PROGRAM THROUGH THEIR WORKPLACE,
AND THAT ESCALATES TO EVEN 20
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO SAVE IF
THAT PROCESS HAPPENS
AUTOMATICALLY, SO THAT'S HOW CAL
SAVERS WORKS. WE, OUR WORKERS,
GET ACCESS TO A SIMPLE IRA STYLE
PLAN THAT SAVES 5% OF WORKERS
PAYCHECKS ON THEIR BEHALF,
INCREASING 1% PER YEAR UP TO 8.
IT'S OPTIONAL, AND THE
PARTICIPANTS CAN CANCEL AT ANY
TIME. THE MONEY IS
PROFESSIONALLY MANAGED AND
INVESTED ON THEIR BEHALF. FOR
EMPLOYERS, THERE ARE NO
OUT-OF-POCKET COSTS. THERE'S NO
EMPLOYER MATCHING CONTRIBUTIONS,
AND THERE'S NO FIDUCIARY
LIABILITY. THOSE ARE ALL THE
MAJOR BARRIERS THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY PREVENTED MID AND
SMALLER SIZE EMPLOYERS FROM
OFFERING THINGS LIKE 401 K'S OR
EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE PENSIONS, SO
HOWEVER, IF THE EMPLOYER DOES
WANT TO OFFER A FOUR, ONE K OR
AN OTHER TAX QUALIFIED PLAN,
THEY'RE FREE TO DO THAT. WE
CONSIDER THAT A WIN AS WELL. THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF CAL SAVERS IS
JUST TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE SAVING.
JUST A QUICK NOTE ON SOME OF OUR
KEY STATS RIGHT NOW FOR THE
GROWING PROGRAM. WE HAVE OVER
HALF A MILLION FUNDED SAVER
ACCOUNTS AS THE PROGRAM IS RUN
OUT, HAS BEEN RAMPED UP $857
MILLION OF ASSETS UNDER
MANAGEMENT AND OVER $1 BILLION.
JUST LAST WEEK, WE CROSSED THE
$1 BILLION MILESTONE FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY SAVERS, WE
HAVE OVER 50,000 EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
ACTIVELY AS OF TODAY, THOSE ARE
FOLKS THAT ARE ACTIVELY MOVING
MONEY FROM PAYCHECKS INTO
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS FOR THEIR
WORKERS. AND OVER 135,000
EMPLOYERS HAVE AT LEAST
REGISTERED AND STARTED THE
PROCESS. THE AVERAGE FUNDED
BALANCE FOR THESE NEW ACCOUNTS
IS $1,715, BUT THAT'S UP 10% IN
JUST THE LAST THREE MONTHS. SO
THE PROGRAM IS GROWING ACTIVELY
RIGHT NOW, IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
REQUEST BEFORE YOU TODAY, WE ARE
REQUESTING $12 MILLION TAKEN IN
THOSE $2 MILLION PER YEAR
INCREMENTS OVER SIX YEARS. THESE
FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO COMPLETE
THE ORIGINAL LOAN REQUIRED TO
START UP THE PROGRAM, AND WILL
BE USED TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
AND GROW THE PROGRAM, INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR EXISTING STAFF,
EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE, ENFORCEMENT
SERVICES THROUGH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD, EXTERNAL CONSULTANTS
AND THE MARKETING,
ADMINISTRATIVE, AND OVERHEAD
COSTS OF RUNNING THE PROGRAM.
THE FASTER WE GROW THE PROGRAM,
THE MORE QUICKLY IT BECOMES
SELF-FUNDED AND THE QUICKER WE
CAN START TO PAY BACK THIS LOAN.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THE CHAIR IS TEMPER
TEMPORARILY LEFT SO I AM IN
CHARGE NOW, COMMENTS FROM LAO.
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS ON THE
SENATE AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING, DANIELLE
BRANDON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT
CAL SAVERS IS A CORE PROGRAM
THAT HELPS MANY OF CALIFORNIA
LOWEST INCOME WORKERS GET ACCESS
TO RETIREMENT SAVINGS, AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
NEEDED. THANKS I GATHER THE
MONEY IS FOR ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM. THAT'S CORRECT. AND
WHILE YOU STATED ITS GROWTH IN
THE AND AVERAGE BALANCE AND THE
LIKE, DOES NOT APPEAR TO ME TO
BE WILDLY SUCCESSFUL, I THIS,
ASSEMBLY, THEN ASSEMBLYMAN
DELEON HE BROUGHT THIS UP
INITIALLY WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO
AND IT WAS ENACTED, I THINK,
WHEN HE WAS IN THE SENATE. IF I
HAVE MY TIMING RIGHT, AND AT THE
TIME, I WAS SOMEWHAT QUESTIONING
OF ITS HOW ITS TRUE
EFFECTIVENESS WOULD BE. BUT, HOW
WOULD YOU REACT TO MY COMMENT
THAT IT REALLY IS NOT PERFORMING
TO THE LEVEL THAT WOULD BE WOULD
HAVE BEEN EXPECTED AT ITS
ADOPTION? THÀNH. WELL, THE
INITIAL PROJECTIONS WERE
HAMPERED BY THE INCONVENIENT
TIMING OF THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
I WILL SAY. SO. THE MANDATE THAT
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO ACTUALLY
EFFECTUATE AND FACILITATE THE
PROGRAM WAS DELAYED BY OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF, SO THAT REALLY
SLOWED THE TIMING FOR THIS. SO I
WOULD SAY, INDEED, IF WE WERE
GOING BACK IN TIME AND LOOKING
AT WHERE WE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE
TODAY BASED ON THOSE ORIGINAL
PROJECTIONS, IT'S BEHIND
SCHEDULE. BUT I WILL JUST POINT
THAT THE PROGRAM HAS REALLY
DOUBLED IN ALMOST EVERY POSSIBLE
METRIC SINCE JUST 2022, SO
REALLY, IN UNDER A TWO YEAR TIME
SPAN, IT'S REALLY SORT OF
REACHING THIS MOMENTUM
EXPONENTIAL TYPE OF GROWTH PHASE
WHERE WE PUSH PAST THE INITIAL
RESISTANCE OF FOLKS WHO ARE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
REQUIRES, THAT MAY HAVE SOME
INITIAL RESISTANCE THAT IS BEING
SLOWLY OVERCOME. AND THE OTHER
PIECE IS THAT THE PROGRAM'S
MANDATE IS BEING EXPANDED, RIGHT
NOW TO INCLUDE EMPLOYERS WITH AS
FEW AS EVEN ONE EMPLOYEE. SO
THAT WAS NOT ORIGINALLY
CONCEPTUALIZED. SO WHAT THAT
DOES IS REALLY EXPAND THE
HORIZONS FOR THE POTENTIAL
GROWTH IN THE FUTURE. SO THE
PROGRAM IS OPEN FOR THOSE
SMALLER EMPLOYERS RIGHT NOW TO
FACILITATE. BUT THE DEADLINE TO
SAY, REALLY YOU HAVE TO DO THIS
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A PROPER
EXEMPTION, DOESN'T HAPPEN UNTIL
THE END OF 2025. SO I WILL
CERTAINLY GRANT THAT THE
PROGRAM, YOU KNOW, COULD BE IN A
MORE ADVANCED POSITION IN THE
STATE. BUT THERE ARE REASONS FOR
THAT, AND WE'RE REALLY ACTIVELY
ADDRESSING THOSE THINGS THROUGH
OUR COMPLIANCE EFFORTS, THROUGH
OUR BRAND AWARENESS EFFORTS, AND
BY TIGHTENING UP SOME OF THE
NUTS AND BOLTS OF THE PROGRAM TO
MAKE IT MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT, BOTH FOR THE
EMPLOYERS AND FOR THE
PARTICIPANTS. THE SAVERS
THEMSELVES. I THINK IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AT SOME POINT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AGAIN AND, AND, SORT OF
REEVALUATE THE POLICY, PERHAPS,
BUT THAT'S JUST MY THOUGHT. AT
ANY RATE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE HERE, SO NO
OTHER QUESTIONS. WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE 21. DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS, THE BREEZE
SYSTEM MAINTENANCE AND CREDIT
CARD FUNDING.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
TAYLOR SCHICK, AND I AM THE
CHIEF FISCAL OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
I THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND ITS ROLE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PROMOTING AND
PROTECTING THE INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS BY SERVING
AS A REGULATORY AGENCY FOR THEIR
HEALTH, SAFETY, AND ECONOMIC
WELL-BEING, AND BY PROMOTING
LEGAL AND ETHICAL STANDARDS OF
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT. THIS IS
DONE THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATORY BOARDS AND BUREAUS,
WHICH SET AND ENFORCE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE
PROFESSIONALS. ESTABLISHMENT AND
BUSINESSES THEY REGULATE, WHICH
RANGE FROM HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO ACCOUNTANTS,
ARCHITECTS, CONTRACTORS,
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALERS AND
VETERINARIANS, TO NAME A FEW.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY 26 BOARDS,
ONE COMMITTEE AND ONE
COMMISSION. UNDER THE BROAD
AUTHORITY OF THE DEPARTMENT, AND
SEVEN BUREAUS AND ONE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM UNDER THE
DIRECT OVERSIGHT OF THE
DEPARTMENT. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
APPROXIMATELY 3500 STAFF AND AN
OVERALL BUDGET OF 749 MILLION.
THE BUDGET IS COMPRISED OF OVER
40 DIFFERENT ITEMS OF
APPROPRIATION AND OVER 60
SPECIAL FUNDS. THESE SPECIAL
FUNDS ARE PRIMARILY SUPPORTED BY
LICENSING FEES ASSESSED TO
ROUGHLY 3.4 MILLION LICENSEES
ACROSS 280 LICENSE TYPES,
PERMITS, CERTIFICATES, AND
REGISTRATIONS. THE DEPARTMENT
HAS TWO PROPOSALS UP FOR
DISCUSSION TODAY, AND I WILL
PROVIDE A SUMMARY OF EACH.
ADDITIONALLY, AND ARE JOINED BY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT WHO ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. OUR FIRST PROPOSAL IS FOR
AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
RELATED REQUEST, WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING 14.7
MILLION IN 2024, 25 AND ONGOING
FOR CONTINUED MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS AND CREDIT CARD
FUNCTIONALITY FOR THE BREEZE
SYSTEM, WHICH SUPPORTS 18 OF THE
DEPARTMENTS, BOARDS AND BUREAUS
OF THIS FUNDING, 9 MILLION IS TO
SUPPORT EXISTING STAFF AND
SOFTWARE COSTS AND 5.7 MILLION
IS TO SUPPORT CREDIT CARD
PROCESSING FEES. OUR NEXT
PROPOSAL IS FOR THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY. THE BOARD IS
REQUESTING A BUDGET AUGMENTATION
OF 1.26 5,000,024 25 AND 1.225
MILLION ON GOING TO FUND FIVE
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND STERILE
COMPOUNDING, RENEWALS AND
INSPECTIONS, AS WELL AS TO
ADDRESS AN OVERALL INCREASE IN
THE BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM.
OPERATIONS. THE BOARD HAS SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
INSPECTIONS, INVESTIGATIONS, AND
LICENSES ON PROBATIONS, AND
THESE RESOURCES WOULD ADDRESS
THOSE. THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
OUR PROPOSALS, AND WE ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S JUST ME, THERE
IS THE QUESTION ABOUT UNIFORMITY
ACROSS ALL DCA ENTITIES WITH
RESPECT TO PASSING ON COSTS.
CONSUMER. CAN YOU EXPOUND ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE? SO I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE CREDIT CARD PROCESSING FEES,
SO RIGHT NOW WE DELEGATE THAT
AUTHORITY TO EACH INDIVIDUAL
BOARD AND BUREAU AS A BUSINESS
DECISION THAT THEY CURRENTLY
MAKE, THAT BEST FITS THEIR
NEEDS. SO RIGHT NOW IT'S THE
BOARD AND BUREAU'S DISCRETION ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CHOOSE TO
PASS ON THAT FEE TO THE CONSUMER
OR ABSORB THAT FEE INTERNALLY.
WAS THERE ADDITIONAL COMMENT
FROM EITHER THE LÀ OR DODD? ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. THAT WILL TAKE
CARE OF ISSUES 21 AND 22. AND I
THINK THAT BRINGS US TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION.
WELCOME AND, PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS SOPHIA SMITH, AND I AM THE
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
ADMINISTRATION AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION, WHERE WE ARE FOCUSED
ON PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
FOSTERING RESPONSIBLE INNOVATION
IN THE FINANCIAL MARKETPLACE.
WITH ME TODAY ARE KHALIL MOHSENI
, CHIEF DEPUTY COMMISSIONER.
NICOLE HISATOMI, DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF LEGISLATION.
SUZANNE MARTINDALE, SENIOR
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION,
MELINDA LEE, DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
OF DEBT COLLECTORS AND MICHAEL
NELSON, ACTING DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF BROKER DEALER
INVESTMENT ADVISORS. THE DSP IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SAFEGUARDING
CONSUMER RIGHTS AND ENSURING
FINANCIAL STABILITY. WE OVERSEE
A VARIETY OF FINANCIAL SERVICES,
PRODUCTS AND PROFESSIONALS. THE
DEPARTMENT REGULATES STATE
LICENSED FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS BANKS, CREDIT UNIONS,
MONEY TRANSMITTERS AND PREMIUM
FINANCE COMPANIES BY CLOSELY
MONITORING THEIR OPERATIONS. THE
DSP PROMOTES COMPLIANCE WITH
STRICT STANDARDS, THEREBY
BUILDING TRUST AND CONFIDENCE
AMONG CONSUMERS. ADDITIONALLY,
THE DSP EXTENDS ITS REGULAR
REGULATORY REACH TO INCLUDE
VARIOUS FINANCIAL BUSINESSES
LIKE SECURITIES BROKERS AND
DEALERS, INVESTMENT ADVISERS,
AND PROVIDERS OF DEFERRED
DEPOSIT SERVICES, COMMONLY KNOWN
AS PAYDAY LOANS. THROUGH
LICENSING AND REGULATION, THE
DEPARTMENT UPHOLDS INDUSTRY
STANDARDS, PROMOTES ETHICAL
CONDUCT, AND PROTECTS VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS AGAINST PREDATORY
PRACTICES. THE DSP ALSO PLAYS A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN REGULATING THE
OFFER AND SALE OF SECURITIES
FRANCHISES AND OFFER AND OFF
EXCHANGE COMMODITIES BY
ENFORCING REGULATIONS IN THESE
AREAS, THE DEPARTMENT ENSURES
INVESTOR PROTECTION, PROMOTES
MARKET INTEGRITY AND CREATES A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS. LASTLY, THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION LAW REPRESENTS A
LANDMARK EXPANSION OF THE DSP
OVERSIGHT CAPABILITIES, AIMING
TO BOLSTER CONSUMER PROTECTION,
FOSTER RESPONSIBLE FINANCIAL
INNOVATION, AND STIMULATE JOB
GROWTH. THE LEGISLATION MARKS A
SIGNIFICANT MILESTONE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE DSP, GRANTING IT
UNPRECEDENTED AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE PREVIOUSLY UNREGULATED
SECTORS BY ALLOWING REGULATION
BY ACTIVITY INSTEAD OF LICENSE.
CATEGORY EXAMPLES OF THESE
INDUSTRIES INCLUDE DEBT
COLLECTION, DEBT RELIEF SERVICES
AND CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES
AND CREDIT REPAIR COMPANIES. AS
WE NAVIGATE THE COMPLEXITIES OF
OUR FINANCIAL LANDSCAPE, THE DSP
SERVES AS A BEACON OF
ACCOUNTABILITY, TRANSPARENCY,
AND CONSUMER EMPOWERMENT BY
UPHOLDING THE HIGHEST STANDARDS
OF THE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT, THE
DEPARTMENT NOT ONLY PROTECTS
CONSUMERS INTERESTS BUT ALSO
FOSTERS A ROBUST AND RESILIENT
RESILIN FINANCIAL MARKETPLACE
FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. THE DSP HAS THREE
BC IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET, BUT ONLY TWO ARE UP FOR
DISCUSSION. THE FIRST ONE IS THE
CONTINUING THÀNH OF CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
ASSEMBLY. WOMAN LEMONS AB 1864
BILL PASSED IN 2020, WHICH HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY BROADENED THE
STATE'S CAPABILITY TO SAFEGUARD
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST ABUSIVE AND
PREDATORY FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES. WITH $14 BILLION IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR 55
POSITIONS, THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO OVERSEE AND
REGULATE FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION LAW, WE
WILL SAFEGUARD CALIFORNIANS FROM
ABUSIVE AND PREDATORY PRACTICES
WITHIN THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY
AND PROMOTE CONSUMER PROTECTION
AND FINANCIAL WELL-BEING. WE
WILL CONTINUE ROBUST EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH PROGRAMS AIMED AT
INCREASING CONSUMER AWARENESS
AND FINANCIAL LITERACY,
EMPOWERING INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS AND RESIST
PREDATORY PRACTICES BY EQUIPPING
CALIFORNIA WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
AND TOOLS THEY NEED TO NAVIGATE
THE FINANCIAL LANDSCAPE
EFFECTIVELY, WE CAN STRENGTHEN
THEIR ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM EXPLOITATION.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, FOR YOUR TIME AND
PATIENCE. PLEASE LET US KNOW IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. AS MUCH
COMMENTS FROM ELIO TOF. ALL
RIGHT, THIS IS TAKEN A WHILE.
WHY IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CCPA.
SENATOR HAS TAKEN A WHILE AND WE
INDICATED AS MUCH BACK IN 2020
WHEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAME TOGETHER TO
PROPOSE AS PART OF THE 2020 2021
BUDGET, THE CFP PACKAGE, WHICH
INCLUDED INCLUDED DOZENS OF
POSITIONS, PHASED IN OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD. SO WE GOT A
TRANCHE IN 2021, A TRANCHE IN
2022 AND THEN 2023. WE INDICATED
THAT GIVEN THE SIZE, SIZE OF THE
EXPANSION, BROADER SUPERVISORY,
REGULATORY AND ENFORCEMENT
POWERS OVER THE FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY WRIT LARGE, THIS IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
BUILD. AND SO WE ARE NOW THREE
YEARS IN, AS PROMISED, RETURNING
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO ASK FOR A
CONTINUATION OF OUR CURRENT
HEADCOUNT. THIS IS CURRENT FLAT
HEADCOUNT BACK IN 2020, WE WERE
GIVEN ONLY THREE YEARS OF
FUNDING AUTHORITY. SO THAT'S WHY
WE'RE BACK HERE AGAIN, TO TALK
ABOUT THE PROGRESS WE'VE HAD IN
IMPLEMENTING THE LAW. BUT QUITE
FRANKLY, AS DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
SMITH ADMITTED OR NOTED, IT IS
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED. IT IS
MODELED AFTER THE AUTHORITIES OF
THE FEDERAL CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU. IT IS A
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT STATUTE
FROM THE ONES WE'VE HISTORICALLY
ADMINISTERED, WHERE IT'S ONE
INDUSTRY SEGMENT, ONE LICENSING
PROGRAM. A LOT MORE DETAIL IN
STATUTE. THERE'S A LOT THAT
WE'VE HAD TO FLESH OUT THROUGH
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT, PROPOSED
REGULATIONS AND THE LIKE. AND
THEN, OF COURSE, YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE
ALONG THE WAY. I HOPE THAT
HELPS. IT DOES. YES, SENATOR. SO
THIS PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED,
DURING THE YEARS THAT WE HAD
FLUSH BUDGETS, ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS WITH LOTS OF EXTRA
MONEY. WOULD WE HAVE THIS IS A
RHETORICAL QUESTION, AND I DON'T
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR AN ANSWER,
WOULD WE HAVE LAUNCHED THIS HAD
THAT YEAR BEEN LIKE THIS YEAR? I
KIND OF DOUBT IT. ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL MOVE THEN. THAT ISSUE WILL
BE HELD OPEN. ISSUE 24 IS
CONTINUATION OF DEBT COLLECTOR
LICENSING AND REGULATION. THANK
YOU. THE DEBT COLLECTOR
LICENSING ACT, SB 908 BILL
PASSED IN 2020, WHICH ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO LICENSE, REGULATE
AND EXAMINE DEBT COLLECTORS WITH
$11.75 MILLION IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR 51 POSITIONS, THE
DEPARTMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE
REGULATIONS TO ENSURE THAT DEBT
COLLECTORS OPERATE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE LAW, PROTECTING
CONSUMERS FROM UNFAIR OR
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES. THIS
INCLUDES STRICT MONITORING OF
COLLECTION TACTICS AND ADHERENCE
TO GUIDELINES OUTLINED IN THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS. WE
WILL REGULARLY ASSESS THE
FINANCIAL HEALTH AND PRACTICES
OF DEBT COLLECTION AGENCIES TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS BY CLOSELY
MONITORING THEIR ACTIVITIES, WE
CAN PROACTIVELY IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL RISKS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM HARMFUL PRACTICES
THAT MAY ARISE WITHIN THEIR
OPERATIONS. WE'LL ALSO ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE WITH LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS AND TAKE
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS AGAINST DEBT
COLLECTORS FOUND IN VIOLATION,
SUCH AS IMPOSING FINES OR TAKING
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE ANY DEBT COLLECTORS
WHO FAIL TO MEET THE NECESSARY
STANDARDS AND ENSURING THAT
CONSUMERS ARE SHIELDED FROM
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR. THANK YOU,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, FOR
YOUR TIME AND PATIENCE. PLEASE
LET US KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. LEO YOU
OFF? ALL RIGHT. THERE WAS A BIT
OF A HICCUP ON THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION,
WHICH CAUSED A LITTLE PROBLEM
GETTING ACCESS TO BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON THE CHECKS. AND
THAT WAS REMEDIED FROM WHAT I
READ IN THE REPORT, WHERE ARE WE
WITH ACCESS TO THAT? DO YOU WANT
ME TO DO THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY? AND YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
WHERE WE'RE CURRENT STATUS? I
JUST WANT TO MAKE YEAH, JUST
ANOTHER THING, SENATOR. I WANTED
TO KIND OF TIE THESE TWO
TOGETHER. SO IN 2020, WE GOT THE
CCPA PACKAGE, WHICH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE WORKED ON AT
THE SAME TIME. IN PARALLEL, SB
908, THE DEBT COLLECTION
LICENSING ACT, BOTH ARE SIGNED
AT THE SAME IN THE SAME YEAR.
AND SO WE FOUND OURSELVES
NEEDING TO PIVOT TO NOT ONLY
START BUILDING THE CPL, BUT ALSO
START BUILDING THIS DEBT
COLLECTOR LICENSING PROGRAM. THE
ORIGINAL STATUTE HAD US DO
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
THROUGH CALIFORNIA. DOJ TO
ACCESS THE FBI RECORDS. WE,
AFTER ALMOST A YEAR OF BACK AND
FORTH AND TRYING TO GET AN
ANSWER FROM FBI, FBI DENIED US.
APPARENTLY THIS IS SOMETHING
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING TO NEW
STATE LICENSING PROGRAMS THAT IS
NOT UNIQUE TO OUR DEPARTMENT. SO
WE DID AMEND THE STATUTE IN 2022
TO GET CONDITIONAL LICENSING
AUTHORITY SO THAT WE COULD ISSUE
CONDITIONAL LICENSES BEFORE
GETTING BACKGROUND CHECKS. THEN
WE AMENDED THE STATUTE YET AGAIN
VIA TRAILER BILL IN 2023 TO
ENABLE US TO INSTEAD OF USING
THE CA DOJ ROUTE INSTEAD AS A
FINANCIAL REGULATOR. WE CAN DO
THIS. USE THE NATIONAL
MULTI-STATE LICENSING SYSTEM,
WHICH ITSELF IS RUN BY THE
CONFERENCE OF STATE BANK
SUPERVISORS AND IS PRE-APPROVED
BY THE FBI. SO THAT'S THE
HISTORY OF HOW WE GOT HERE. AND
THEN DEPUTY COMMISSIONER LEE CAN
TELL YOU THE CURRENT STATUS OF
OUR PROCESSING OF LICENSING
APPLICATIONS. SO WE HAVE
APPROVAL NOW, THE ONLINE
LICENSING SYSTEM HAS BEEN
UPDATED AND IT IS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. WE, AS LET OUR
LICENSEES KNOW AS OF LAST WEEK
THAT THEY HAVE 90 DAYS TO
COMPLETE THE BACKGROUND PROCESS.
SO WE THEN IT WILL TAKE US. THEN
WE HAVE ANOTHER 90 DAYS ON TOP
OF THAT TO ACTUALLY DO OUR PART
OF IT. SO WE EXPECT IT IN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS. IT WILL BE
COMPLETELY DONE. ALL OF OUR
BACKLOG WILL BE CLEARED AND
GOING TO MOVE. THE MIC IS GOING
TO MOVE THE MIC A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO YOU, JUST TO BE SURE
WE'RE ON THE RIGHT. YOU HAVE TO
REPEAT EVERYTHING. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WAS THAT CLEAR TO
MEMBERS? ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, I
WILL BRING IT TO THE SUB. ANY
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. APPRECIATE.
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'LL BRING US TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
DOCKET TODAY. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE TO
ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON A
MATTER ON THE DOCKET, THE
COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED IN YOUR
COMMENTS AND WELCOMES YOUR
PARTICIPATION. PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME, WE'LL ASK
YOU TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
ABOUT A MINUTE. WELCOME. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. SENATORS, SARAH
FLAX, I'M HERE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON ITEMS 12
AND 13. THE CAL COMPETES PROGRAM
OF GO-BIZ, I WANT TO SAY IN
ADVANCE THAT I UNDERSTAND, AND
WE ARE VERY, VERY AWARE THAT
THERE IS A BUDGET DEFICIT AND
THERE ARE CORE PROGRAMS THAT OUR
MEMBERS BOTH ADMINISTER AND
DEPEND ON. SO I AM NOT
ADVOCATING FOR FUNDING FOR CAL
COMPETES, BUT I AM HERE TO SAY
THAT IF THIS FUNDING GOES
FORWARD AND FOR THE EXISTING
PROGRAM, WE DO ADVOCATE FOR
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND AN
UPDATE TO THE STANDARDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM, BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS, IS CREATING HIGH
QUALITY JOBS THAT MEANS NOT JUST
NET JOB, NEW NET JOB CREATION,
BUT THAT THERE ARE LIVING AND
FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES WITH
BENEFITS, GOOD WORKING
CONDITIONS, AND THAT THERE'S THE
TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION SO THAT THERE'S
THOROUGH VETTING. SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, MISS FOXX.
ANYBODY ELSE LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON ANY ITEM ON THE
DOCKET TODAY, SEEING NO ONE VERY
GRATEFUL, WE HAVE ASKED, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS TO MAKE HER WAY
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM. I DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE AN ETA ON THAT
OR NOT, OR IF WE NEED TO,
PROCEED AND HOLD OPEN, WE CAN DO
THAT IN THE INTEREST OF SENATOR
NELLO'S TIME, WE'LL SEGREGATE
THE ITEMS ON THE VOTE ONLY,
CALENDAR INTO TWO GROUPS, GROUP
NUMBER ONE WILL BE ISSUES ONE
THROUGH EIGHT AND TEN THROUGH
11, I HAVE A INQUIRY ABOUT THE
RULES FOR MAKING, IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE FOR CHAIR TO MOVE, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. SO WE MAY BE
STUCK BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF MEMBERS. OR I CAN
MOVE. YOU CAN MOVE THAT. YOU CAN
MOVE THIS MATCH. ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. I
THINK THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE AS BUDGETED. MR. NILO, I
NÓ NÓ MAKE THE MOTION. I'M
SORRY, HE SAID MR. AEILLO, MY
EAR IS PLAYING TRICKS ON ME. I
MOVE THOSE ITEMS. THANK YOU, THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE AS BUDGETED
, CONSULTANT. CALL THE ROLL,
PADILLA. AYE. PADILLA. I, NILO I
NILO I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THANK
YOU. WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN ON
THAT AND MOVE TO GROUP NUMBER
TWO, WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
SAME QUESTION, I THINK WE'LL
HAVE TO WAIT ON THAT. I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A MOTION. I
BELIEVE. YES. IS THAT CAN WE
CONFIRM THAT THIS IS THESE ARE
NEW RULES TO ME. SO I WANT TO BE
SURE. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR NILO,
COURTESY MOTION. ALL RIGHT. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PADILLA AYE. PADILLA AYE. NILO.
NØ. NILO NØ CUEVAS. THE GROUP
TWO WILL BE HELD OPEN, THANK
YOU, SENATOR NILO. AND WE WILL
AWAIT THE RETURN OF SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
OH OKAY. WELL. I LIKE.
THANK YOU. I DO. I JUST. TO. Ó.
YEAH YEAH
.
ALL RIGHT. SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FOUR WILL RECONVENE, AND WE WILL
LIFT THE CALL AS TO THE VOTE.
ONLY ITEMS. GROUP ONE IS ISSUES
ONE THROUGH EIGHT AND TEN
THROUGH 11. MOTION. GO AHEAD.
REPORT CONSULTANT, CALLING THE
ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS,
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I ALL RIGHT, WE'LL LIFT
THE CALL AS TO ISSUE NUMBER
NINE. GROUP TWO CALLING ABSENT
MEMBERS. CUEVAS I SAW CUEVAS, I
ALL RIGHT, THOSE ISSUES ARE OUT
WITH NILO VOTING NO. AS TO ISSUE
NUMBER NINE. AND WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATION. ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENT CAN DO SO VIA THE
WEBSITE OR DIRECT TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AT THIS TIME,
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL STAND
ADJOURNED